this is jocko podcast number 331 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening also joining
us for the back to back episodes ben
milligan author of the book by water
beneath the walls
if you haven't listened to podcast 330
go back and listen that one if you
really want to start at the beginning of
the ben milligan experience
then you got to go back and listen to
ben milligan a former seal teammate of
mine
who has written this incredible book
about
about the history of special operations
and how from this convoluted contorted
history
there ends up being this random
group of men
from the navy
that
become the
[Music]
go anywhere commando of choice
for the military
so there you go ben well said thanks
thanks for coming back man said better
than i could uh
so we got barely in three hours on the
last podcast we got through world war ii
in in this convoluted crazy story of
hits and misses of surfaces and gaps
and
we're gonna roll into
now the post-war period
post-war korea
when i was writing the book i
i really didn't want to uh have a book
that was half world war ii and half
everything else but it's kind of how
how it ended
with a podcast that's half world war ii
and then halfway i mean how how can you
not though like when i was thinking
about it like i cover uh six chapters on
uh world war ii and then there's uh
nine chapters of everything else but you
know
a third of the book is you know world
war ii and you know justifiably so and
world war ii is you know dwarfs
everything else that we've ever
you know
the most horrible war in history and
you know in my world war ii section it
covers you know six different theaters
of operation so
i mean it makes sense that it would so
i don't feel as bad about it when i set
out yeah yeah um
all right so let's jump into chapter 7
which is the u.s navy's post-war plight
and the sailor raiders who led her back
to significance in korea
good title yeah we will continue you can
see we continue uh ben with his
long-winded
chapter titles so those aren't even
subtitles right there that's the actual
chapter title each chapter title is the
chat is a chapter one that's the chapter
title and then the subtitle is that yeah
because uh
this chapter could have been called
chapter seven post war in my defense i
had much tighter chapter titles until my
editor got a hold of these i like i like
how you're taking ownership of that i
like how you're blaming your editor no
you're right it is it is the other
person's fault you're right it is
i happen to like my chapter title and
for some of these i spend more time
writing the chapter titles you imagine
trying to compress 30 years of uh you
know a chapter into you know a single
sentence like you're just i mean you're
doing that absolutely best that you can
so like one give your your reader some
idea of what's about to you know what
they're about to you know undertake but
two you don't want to give away anything
you don't want to say like i mean i
think the only chapter that i really
give away you know i i sort of i give
you you know some foreshadowing you know
the the raid that wasn't which is the
chapter on the rangers you have some
sense that this isn't going to go the
way that they think it's going to go and
then two uh the um
the the the first chapter on the raiders
you know the the the the
the rise and the violent demise right
the navy's first raiders you want you
know you're kind of you're giving your
reader like a little taste of what's
about to come mm-hmm
i i know i can be a little bit of a of a
what is it a dart thrower from the back
of the room about your about your titles
and stuff but uh as i said
this book is phenomenal
this book is is
when i when i read through this book um
look the detail is amazing but you're a
freaking hell of a writer too it's funny
there's the the things that you capture
the things that you call out the
dialogue that you selected and what's
cool is the dialogue that you selected
this is dialogue that's documented this
isn't like your uh authors you don't do
that anywhere in the you don't do
anywhere in the book do you do the you
know this is basically what was said you
don't do that anywhere do you
it's all
this is what was actually said recorded
in this document
there's only one time where i i try to
synthesize a conversation i think
that's when i have two different i had
two documents uh one was donovan's
account of a conversation
and then miles as count what a
conversation and they both you know are
sort of like confirming what the other
said
um that's the only time where i tried to
synthesize you know two separate
conversations or there was another time
when i was synthesizing you know the
conversation that uh um hal and matt
smith has with kelly turner about tinian
and then there's a third
um
uh uh account where uh draper kaufman is
listening in on this conversation i'm
trying to like do my best to like
squeeze these three things into
triangulate the different perspectives
and try and come up with something
that's to work essentially like agree
with each other though i mean it's like
you know uh
uh you kind of know when something's
true
when it doesn't exactly agree like if uh
you know
you're a platoon commander and uh you
know two of your guys uh show up for an
op and they both have black eyes and
you're like what happened last night and
if they both have the exact same story
you know they're lying yeah
you know what i mean so if there's a
slight if there's you know they both
kind of rhyme with each other but
they're not exactly the same they were
just told from a different perspective
yeah but
well it's it's an unbelievable book it's
a fantastic read and it's kind of book
also you can kind of pick up
this is this is sort of in the vein of
about face where an about face you can
pick up that book and you can start to
read it and in four pages three pages
you go oh that's a good little lesson
there's something to think about and
this is this this is the same way that
this book works
yes absolutely you read it from cover to
cover but you have it sitting on your
you know on your on your nightstand and
you're not quite tired yet open this
book up anywhere you read
three or four pages and you get a little
less in a little piece of history and
also some kind of a leadership lesson in
there
so phenomenal from that perspective as
well um all right let's jump into this a
little bit so
tell me more about the revolt of the
admirals what happened with that so
after world war ii uh the
uh
the
joint chiefs or
there's a there's a huge budget you know
cut i mean
there's nothing's ever happened like
world war ii um
and
world war ii like nothing's ever
happened like the end of world war ii
where you know the military you know the
the us military prior to world war ii
has always had this um
uh sort of cycle where they they they
build up to deal with that with whatever
conflict whether it was the american
civil war or the first world war or the
second world war they they grew from
sort of a nucleus force to this massive
industrial you know uh mobilized you
know military and then after it
you shrink back down to that nucleus
force again so you can rebuild it uh
again later after world war ii um
the us military or the the
the u.s public has finally learned its
lesson we can't
shrink back you can't
be in this industrial or this uh
era of total war and not uh field planes
and massive ships you have to keep a
residual uh
force
a float and in the air
but there's still you can't continue to
spend what they were spending in world
war ii so the military shrinks
drastically so all the military
entities are competing for very limited
resources
but
now that uh all of the you know worlds
or all of the
united states enemies have been defeated
um
the the one that still exists is the
soviet union and
planners don't expect that this is going
to be a massive
naval effort the soviet union at that
point doesn't have a you know a
particularly big navy or anything like
that we don't anticipate that we're ever
going to need to
land ships in the soviet or land troops
on the soviet union because we have this
you know
a huge
presence in in western europe
so
planners in the army and the air force
are
claiming that they need more of the
resources that the navy doesn't need
resources because we're never going to
have amphibious warfare again
it's just just not going to happen
anything that the navy could have done
all the all the troops that the navy
could have transported the air force can
do it with planes
or we're already ashore anyway so
take the money from
the navy
give it to the army give it to
especially give it to the air force so
the air force and the and the army have
convinced uh you know most of the
the top decision makers
in the truman administration that
they're going to you know pull money you
know rob from peter to paypal
well the navy
sees this prospect of what
is about to be done to them about to be
done to their service and not only are
they about to lose all of this money
and all this status but they're about to
be sort of de-clawed you know the navy's
not going to be like a force a defensive
warfare force anymore um and the navy
planners are you know they're they're
they're panicking
not just panicking for their their
service but they realize how um how
difficult how complex expeditionary
warfare is and they're doing everything
they can to
save their service by saving the service
save the country
um
so
uh they stage essentially stage a coup
they uh um
not a not a not a coup but they uh
the the
they start
leaking pressure or leaking stuff to
newspaper columnist
i talked about merit merit edson read
mike edson he
resigns from his
commission in the marine corps so he can
get out and start protesting publicly uh
eventually uh the clamor gets so bad
that they have to call a committee
hearing uh in the house in in congress
um and it's you know for several days uh
it's a it's a big to-do like uh they
bring in just about every admiral uh
every every famous admiral from world
war ii to testify in front of congress
yeah i got i got a list of names here uh
leahy
blandy nimitz halsey spruance kincaid
connolly carney burke
every blue water hero save kelly turner
uh save kelly turner farragut john paul
jones
um
that is just basically everyone you
could every pipe-hitting
naval leader goes in and uh
makes their case makes their case for
not
taking all the money away from the navy
and giving it all to the army and
primarily the air force
no other force and no other nation
denfield proclaimed could concentrate
aircraft like the navy could seize
advanced bases could defend those bases
could promulgate underseas and
amphibious warfare could bring to
barrett's underwater demolition teams
it's mine sweepers and its radio
telephone operators to control air and
naval gunfire
at the conclusion of denfield's
testimony a red-faced speechless
matthews stood and thundered from the
committee room for a moment it appeared
the navy had won
interesting they even mentioned the
underwater demolition teams i mean
they're so i'm uh i mean important in
the navy's order of battle at that point
that absolutely they're going and you
know they grew like you say in the book
they grew from three teams
to 40 teams and each of these teams is
100 as 100 guys
plus each one is assigned its own ship
and not only that but they have a
assorted um uh
all the all the protection that each one
of these teams requires
almost each one gets an lcig gunboat
plus all the battleships that came with
that i mean the the udts have risen to
the front rank of the navy's amphibious
warfare plan
so
but it fails
the whole revolt fails
and that's that
sort of i mean it's that until we go
until
uh
a completely unexpected event happens
the north koreans invade the south
that's what we always need to be ready
for that unexpected event an unexpected
event that no one no one anticipates
one of the things that we've been doing
as we've been going through this book uh
the second time here is talk about some
of the characters that you were forced
to cut out
because of just
the prudence and and
and
uh sympathy for your readers what you'd
like to tell me sympathy for the reader
because you would you could literally
make every one of these characters its
own book so tell me about louis a
johnson lewis a johnson is
i mean he's he's a villain out of
central casting he's
i mean he's a total politician he's uh
um
i think he's a west he's a yeah i know
he is he's a west virginia attorney he's
uh
truman's campaign director
in his second campaign for office
his reward
for
getting truman a second term is he
becomes the
secretary of defense uh a position he's
um not particularly suited for he
doesn't have a a huge military record he
he did serve in the first world war i
think he was a supply officer
one of the things he did one of the last
things he did when he was still on
active duty as a as a or as an army
supply officer as he issued a fairly uh
fairly scathing report of uh the the
sort of the army's logistics efforts
he's always kind of been um not an
outsider but sort of a uh you know like
the guy with the flamethrower he just he
does not like the institution that he
was a part of he thinks it could be run
so much better and when he sees the um
the us military he sees redundancies
everywhere not just redundancies but
waste waste waste he wants to get rid of
all of it he wants to come in like i
said with a blowtorch and he wants to he
stops production of a an aircraft
carrier while it's i mean after its keel
has already been laid he's taking money
from the navy and giving it right to the
air force almost 400 million dollars in
one fell swoop from the navy to the to
the air force um
he is i i say he's a person who never
saw an arm without thinking how to twist
it
one of my favorite lines from the book
like he was
um
and uh
yeah i mean he's he's the he's the uh i
call him he's the
he's the he's the villain of the navy
he's the he's the antagonist he's uh
he's the guy who sees you know the navy
is just a you know waste of manpower
waste of resources the air force can do
everything particularly with with atomic
weapons nobody else has them there's no
more war this is the end of history for
a lot of people they think everything's
we're done perpetual peace
you know what's uh when i first got into
the navy when i was a kid
i i remember at some point you know i
got to the team because
in buds you're still in boot camp and
then buds you're still kind of like
isolated to what the navy actually is
and how it actually works right
i remember going on my first trip
at the seal teams and
for some reason we had to like
get gas for our vehicles
and we had to pay for the gas from the
navy
like uh supply depot thing we had a
special card
and i thought well
you think you think just like hey man
it's the navy like they got gas it's
navy gas like we're in the navy there in
the navy hey cool
or oh we need to fly to some other state
cool well the air force is going to pick
us up and then we don't have to pay for
that they're in the air force we're in
the navy but we're all on the same big
team
and you realize it's not like that at
all and that's why these budgetary
discussions that happen they're so cr
you wouldn't think that they would be a
thing but they're they're the thing it's
not just that they're offing they are
the thing and the way this money gets
divvied up and luckily
luckily it ends up being
for the most part a positive sort of
competitive
cycle of people trying to do good so
that they can get more money which
drives
better results right
uh
but but when you talk about efficiency
like if you were to look at the military
just straight up from a pure efficiency
why does the army have boats why does
the army have helicopters why does the
navy have helicopters why does the
marine corps have
fighter jets
why you could just say well it doesn't
make any sense at all this is all
redundant if you're gonna have one group
in charge of the sky make it the air
force you make one group in charge of
the ocean make it the make it the navy
got one group in charge of the land make
it the army
there's all kinds of efficiencies that
you could kind of
think and say yeah that makes some sense
but the reality is there's these seams
and the seams need to be dealt with and
and then you
you want to have in a positive way you
want to have
the marine corps that has fighter jets
and the navy has fighter jets and the
air force has fighter jets
and the army well they have a10s
so
close but
you see what i'm saying but they all
have no i mean you're right bradley
fighting vehicles and and you know
armored vehicles well one of the army
has them but so does the marine corps
and you you just go down these lists of
where these things cross over where the
efficiencies are and so this battle that
we're talking about that's a that's a
economic battle for the various forces
is a real thing that needs to be
contended with and and that's sort of
another thing as we go forward
that's going to continue to drive the
seals
to be coming to get created
because
as
you know you mentioned oh it seems like
world war ii was sort of the end of war
for some people
well
if you want to talk about naval battles
navy versus navy
it gets pretty close to saying that
world war ii is the end of
war
right it does
for the navy
and so then what's the navy doing well
we still got aircraft okay that's cool
but that still is one step back
from the people that are on the front
lines making things happen
so i just wanted to bring that up from
the perspective of where this all goes
and how this all plays out
uh
ted fielding let's deal with ted
fielding
ted fielding mack poynt and george
atchison these are all characters that
are udt
officers who
are are almost lost to history um
they are uh
they're that first rank of uh
of frogmen
that um
it i kind of got to go back real quick
so when korea kicks off
um korea the geography of korea you know
determines a lot the
um
korea is uh it's a peninsula
it's accessible you know everywhere you
know on every every coast of it you know
by you know naval guns uh navy ships um
but the the mountains of korea
uh kind of preclude you know the um
uh the highways being you know driven or
built right down the center of the
country so most of the highways in korea
most of the railroads in korea
all like all major
traffic is going to go up and down the
skins of the country so on either coast
you know within 15 miles of the coast um
the the major arteries of the country
are going to be you know established so
when the inman gun or where the north
korean army when they attack they they
push the south korean military and the
and the u.s advisors they push them into
this little pocket you know down to the
far southeast corner of the country what
we call the busan perimeter and the
north koreans are
supplying uh their forces that are
attacking this perimeter you know up and
down these railways that are uh you know
on the on the flanks of the coast or on
the flanks of the peninsula so
the us military having disbanded the
army rangers having disbanded the army
raid or the marine corps raiders the
marine back recon company all of these
special operations units that had been
created in world war ii none of these
units exist
and all commanders want is to start
fielding something that can help cut
these supply lines
to the north korean army
and the first
entity to see the opportunity there and
to see you know the the good that they
can be doing on that are the commanders
in the u.s navy they see these but they
don't have the troops to do it and the
only troops that are in country
uh that they have
are
their frogmen the underwater demolition
teams and they've never done any
missions like this they've never gone
ashore the furthest the udts have gone
ashore
are in okinawa a couple of guys went
inland to do a
handful of things but nothing serious so
when we get to korea
because they're you know there are no
raiders there are no rangers there are
uh the recon uh the marine recon are
still on their way to the country um
the opportunity falls to the only unit
that's that's there and that's a
detachment of udt frogman
and they it out and they start going
ashore and they start uh they they do
their they find these railways and they
try to blow them up with the i mean well
the one thing that the udt has is a ton
of explosives
we've got some bombs we got some bombs
we i mean they uh i think the first raid
uh that they they actually uh undertake
is in yosu and it's by george atchison
who's um
uh
he's a relatively uh new frogman he's
not he wasn't a uh a frogman in world
war ii um but he's a uh he
he um
he's become a really good problem solver
in his you know four-year career in the
udts uh he's one of the one of the first
guys to participate in what what's
called the sub ops um uh platoon he he's
he started to instead of being just the
the frogman who's swimming on the
surface he's uh he's perfected uh
lockouts from submarines um he's driven
underwater submersibles so he he
may he might not be a raider or might
not be somebody who's trained in you
know inland uh demolition raids but he
is somebody who's adaptable and he leads
one of the first raids ashore to blow up
a railroad a rail railway
and those subsequent guys that come in
fielding boynton they they only take the
udts even further
i'm going to take it to the book on that
one
below the wall and out of atchison's
view foley had likewise heard the hand
cart and was already splashing into the
surf his legs and arms straining against
the slow motion of sucking water and the
bad dream unfolding behind him when he
reached the rubber boat he gave a a
hushed alarm to the crew grabbed the
tommy gun and splashed back through the
surf swimmers limey austin and mccormick
waiting uh waiting behind to keep up
under the bridge atchison held his
breath waiting for an opportunity
suddenly a shadowy figure breasted the
sea wall and charged the tunnel firing a
machine gun from the hip instinctively
both the north koreans and atchison
opened fire at the same target
apparently just in time to hear the
figure yelling hang in there lt i'm
coming
it was foley whether or not atchison
realized his mistake the flash of
gunfire unfroze him grenade in hand he
pulled the pin and threw it toward the
north koreans then he threw another and
another the sequence of explosions all
of unknown origin chased the north
koreans back into the tunnel
glimpsing his moment atchison tore
himself from cover and sprinted to the
seawall
as soon as he reached the top of the
wall one of the armed swimmers huddled
at the bottom spotted a human head
poking over the lip and made the same
mistake atchison had had and stitched
the wall with fire
one of the rounds tore a hole in the
bill of atchison's hat
half a second later atchison identified
himself you idiots hold your fire it's
me
and poked his head over again then
scraped down the wall
and onto the rocks
at the bottom he found the rest of his
men having rolled himself away from
danger and over the sea wall foley was
now alert but gritting his teeth shot
through the hand and thigh a kneecap
smashed by his fall
once they were together mccormick
scooped up foley in his arms and
everyone ran for the surf
that medium
that
until this mission the udt had always
considered the furthest limit of their
operations
so that's it that's the first
venture
out of the surf zone and on to the land
foley goes home foley goes to uh
he's
the movie the frogmen comes out a few
months later
and uh foley who's recently returned
from korea uh he goes to the premiere
he's wheeled up in a wheelchair he gets
to meet you know richard woodmark who's
the
um the
the star of the show and everything like
that was pretty cool
that's one of the few things like um
that would have been a totally missed uh
episode had i not gone to the udtco
museum that's one of like
i'm walking through that thing i think i
know everything and i walked past a
picture of richard woodmark and foley
like
damn dude yeah
they kind of did a good job on the frog
man they really did yeah they oh on the
front yeah the movie yeah i mean they
they catch you some good attitudes right
you're like oh i'd know these guys
the kind of first opening 10 minutes
where you're catching the the attitude
of these udt guys you're like oh i
recognize this attitude i freaking had
to hang out with these idiots my whole
life
they're pretty cocky they're just
getting after it
uh they do a good job with that
so then after you you say that fielding
now in boynton they start pushing in and
continuing to push it doesn't have
operations yeah it doesn't happen like
right away so they i mean when the
marine recon gets in country uh the
marine uh they they create this unit
special
operations group or sog uh and it's a
it's another one of those um sort of
entities where the marines take the
front rank of it and the udt take the
subordinate role of just being in charge
of the explosives so the marines are
going to go ashore
they're going to
you know with with guns and everything
like that they're going to clear
or provide a perimeter for the udt to
come ashore with explosives set those
explosives under the railways and then
they escape toward it now they they have
uh
a couple of these that sort of they go
sideways
a couple of marines are are wounded
badly once paralyzed on the last of
these raids
a force of frogmen have to
paddle back into shore to rescue their
marine comrades i think
eight of them are hanging out in the
water uh uh and water up to their necks
because they can't swim the the ut's
have to
uh they
uh hand them straps on the boats and
they just pull them out back out to sea
uh but that but that it doesn't stop
there so they this this sort of system
uh the the sog is broken apart not long
after i think they have a three-week um
operational um you know lifespan wait
this the sog the special operations
group there in korea has a three-week
operational career yeah it takes it it
takes it from uh all the way up to uh
september uh right uh right uh when the
the inchon
invasion happens once after inchon you
know that uh the imperative to cut the
supply lines isn't it doesn't exist
anymore because we've cut the enemy in
half so once uh once we take inchon
the the north korean
siege of the busan perimeter falls apart
so
that's not to say that udts are no
longer involved in raids for the rest of
the war what i found the the point of
the whole chapter was less about the
udts and more about
the navy's
preoccupation with
uh
uh partnering with any force
that would uh be able to provide them
raiders so they partner with the uh
they they create sog uh they partner
with korean partisans
they
convinced the army to release
the the the marine the royal marine
commandos the 441 commando
they they essentially steal
the royal marines away from the army
they're supposed to go
serve with the army
admiral burke who's the chief of staff
under turner joy he convinces the army
to let him go
and creates a one undersea raiding force
attached to the uss perch
but he also
just creates a a rating for us to
partner with his udt so at every point
all these entities
are
there they partner with the us navy to
create coastal raiders
at different points these all these
units get plucked away plucked away
pulled away for various reasons but the
navy
um
sort of you know telegraphing its
interest its intent
its desire for its own rating force as
soon as these groups are pulled away
they partner with another one partner
with this one they some i mean at every
point and always sort of the um the
common denominator
in that process are the udts the udt's
never really become like the
the they don't become seals um in fact
there are guys like doug feyne um
uh who wrote writes the book naked
warrior uh he his position is that you
know the udt's future is under the water
we're going i mean we
he has no interest in inland combat and
the the contemporaneous documents that i
found i mean several of them are saying
that you know the
several
naval officers are writing that udt's
the udt
chain of command really does not like
doing this doesn't we i mean the udts
would much
rather stick to the water they've only
done this as an exigency and we
shouldn't rely on the udts as an inland
raiding force we need to create
something different so all the way back
in 1953 you can see some reluctance by
the udt whereas the navy is sort of
pushing the udt into this because the
udt or the navy realizes there's some
real strategic potential here and having
a force that can do that can project
this raiding power from the sea
one of the other forces that we see
surfacing to fill this gap again
is talked about in chapter eight
this is the resurrection of the army's
rangers and the gorilla raid that failed
to forestall their second death
i'm gonna go to the book here
on november 21
puckett's pocket or phuket phuket
rough bucket pocket on november 21
puckett's rangers were loaned to task
force dolphin
two battalions of mostly tanks and
reconnaissance troops intended to range
ahead of the rest of the division
for a unit whose motto in the last war
was rangers lead the way
the promotion from rear guard to
skirmishers was an improvement but still
not what had been intended
on november 24th at 2 p.m machine gun
fire forced the rangers off their tanks
and into the scrub from the valley four
puckett
led a daytime attack to season hold hill
224 during which one ranger was mortally
wounded in the chaos tf dolphins tanks
fired on puckett's men killing two and
wounding six
the next day during tf dolphins phase
movement north enemy fire again opened
up on the column this time from behind
realizing they were suddenly surrounded
the rangers bundled off the tanks
into the middle of a frozen rice patty
and sprinted up hill 205 enemy fire
wounded three more rangers and convinced
one of puckett's two platoon commanders
to desert the company and hide behind
and hide in the valley command post
as darkness fell the rangers clawed out
frozen fox hill holes amid the hills
emaciated pine trees and puckett
scratched down an artillery support plan
his roster numbered 58 souls
at around 10 pm the sound of drums
whistles and bugles rattled the night's
silence
a moment later a cascade of sparks
crackled forth from the slope below
followed by the hard thud of mortars and
grenades than a wave of attackers in tan
winter padded uniforms
the fight that followed was not one the
rangers had been promised
under the ghostly loom of waning red
flares the men fought from the lips of
foxholes like trench soldiers relying on
artillery to splash their slope clean
as with rising tides every wave inched
closer and eroded a bit more
bullets grenades courage
men
after five hours and five waves no
ranger had more than a few rounds left
any man who had not already done so
fixed his bayonet
then came the sixth wave
shot through the chest with shrapnel in
his shoulder pucket ducked into the
bottom of his foxhole wrapped white
knuckles around his radio handset cupped
the receiver close to his mouth and
begged for another salvo of artillery
the response
get in line
a half second after puckett's last
transmission two mortar shells exploded
next to him killing his remaining west
point classmate and peppering holes from
his feet to his shoulders
when he woke up
he laughed
there was nothing else to do
all around puckett's men either snaked
down the hill or fought to the death
holy mary of god damn this rifle one
catholic ranger was heard to curse as he
wrenched open his frozen bolt
the last report of wilbur clanton one of
the us army army's first black rangers
was the unmistakable sound of him
roaring in rage as he charged a cluster
of enemy troops with an empty rifle
he was never seen again
three privates first class nearly made
it to the valley floor when they were
stopped not by the enemy
but by the wind that fills their sails
of bravery
their duty
past looters and battlefield
executioners the three stalwarts crept
over scrub and bodies until they found
puckett alive but reeling on his hands
and knees
as they dragged him away he was heard
muttering the same thing over and over
i'm a ranger i'm a ranger
months later mcgee would pen a letter to
puckett in the hospital commending him
and the eighth army rangers for carrying
forth the fullest interpret
interpretation of duty honor and country
this personal satisfaction of doing the
job concluded mcgee is the highest and
often the only reward of a soldier
in the entire letter mcgee betrayed not
a trace of bitterness at the rangers
misuse
of puckett's 57 men who started the
battle on hill 205 17 were wounded and
11 killed their bodies destined for the
same fate as those at cisterna
the enemy was estimated to have numbered
around 600 and they were not north
koreans
with some 300 000 troops
china had entered the war
ralph puckett was just uh well not just
but um a year ago two years ago he was
awarded the medal of honor
his distinguished service cross was
upgraded upgraded
i've always wondered what happened to
the three that rescued him
if they were appropriately honored
that's no small thing to creep back up
that hill with the chinese soldiers
yeah that's kind of that's crazy
uh
and is this the raid that that failed to
forestall their second death no that's
not so this is uh that's an example of
kind of the army's um
misuse of the rangers so the a.m again
yeah the eighth army rangers are created
in country uh they're created um
by john mcgee who's uh the central
character of this book he was a
prisoner of war uh he he fought at
bataan
he was a prisoner of war for most of uh
world war ii he escapes uh and he tries
anyway he he tries to create a partisan
force fails to do that in world war ii
but this is his second chance and so uh
he is ordered to
explore the idea of uh creating a par a
partisan force at the beginning of the
korean war he doesn't find an
opportunity therefore
for that but he does establish an idea
for the the rangers at the same time
he's doing this the army
back in the united states is also
getting the idea to reconstitute the
rangers
so there's sort of two parallel things
that are happening one there's the
eighth army rangers that uh back uh in
the united states they're they're back
at uh fort benning they're recreating
the ranger uh company model
but nobody really up top is thinking
about how to employ these rangers and
one how to like create a command to you
know make sure that the rangers do
ranger missions so
once these rangers are created
unfortunately all these ranger companies
get attached to divisions once the
divisions have them they don't really
know what to do with them so they just
treat them like regular infantry so
they've been trained for you know these
behind the lines raids only a couple of
behind the lines raids happen so what
the only thing that could have really
forestalled that second death would have
been
a a raid that showed the potential
of these rangers and the raid that could
have done that that almost succeeds is
the virginia one raid which is sort of a
combination of um
mcgee's partisan
entities and his ranger entities he
creates this ranger-led partisan
partisan
mission to sneak 25 miles behind enemy
lines to a to a inland
mountain tunnel to destroy that tunnel
to cut the the enemy supply lines and as
you'll find in the book
it's a complete disaster
and was it
how was the research on that did you run
into some issues with the research yeah
it wasn't that it was a tough one to
research it was a um i knew that this
this was the raid that you know i knew
that was uh that i wanted to cover in
part because it did so many things it
did so much work for me it combined you
know these sort of two wings of the
armies
won their
their reconstitution of the rangers but
also the army's you know interest in
partisan or guerrilla operations into a
single mission uh but i couldn't find a
ton
on this i had communicated with a
guy who had formerly served with mcgee
and the partisan command who'd written
a a book
on this mission
ed evanhoh i talked to his son got notes
that his dad had used to write his book
i wasn't until
i was
doing my research for
or
research um
or i came across a pow report for mcgee
so mcgee had been a pow in world war ii
and i knew that
one of the members of the virginia one
raid had also
been a pow so
knowing these pow reports existed in the
archives i did a foia request to see if
there was a pow report of similar length
for
martin
watson now the pow report that i had
from mcgee was like two pages long
i anticipated that i'd have a two two
page report for
martin watson as well
after waiting a couple of months i
finally got a
email back saying yes we have the report
um i said great can you email me the
copy of the report
it's like no it's in another report it's
about 750 pages long like
what can you just pull martin watson's
section out they said no it's 750 pages
like okay right clearly there's a
miscommunication here i'll get it the
next time i'm in you know maryland
next time i was in maryland i spent a
whole day researching something else i
had moved on from the virginia one raid
i was like i'm never going to find
anything on this i'm going to have to
recalibrate come up with something else
that shows what i'm trying to show
um end of the day i was like oh yeah
there's that martin watson pow report so
i requested it they you know wheeled it
out in the box i open the box
i pull it open there's this huge binder
and i'm expecting to leave through it
and find the martin watson section of
this pow report
and when in fact every single page in
this 750 page collection of papers is
all about martin watson and the virginia
one raid
it was they wrote the chapter for me it
was
everything was there so
let me go to the book on martin watson
because this guy's
well he's martin watson raised in
hartford connecticut's frog hollow
district by the competing last stripes
of an irish catholic diocese a german
grandmother and local french bullies
martin r watson red haired fair-skinned
and small had survived by learning the
languages of each group
by building his body until his back was
the size of a dinner table and his legs
could not fit into store bought swim
trunks and by joining up with a gang of
local irish tufts who were destined for
the usual options of east coast irish
destiny law enforcement or crime
with 75 arrests by the time he was 19.
the last one requiring seven police
officers to detain him watson's future
would have undoubtedly been the latter
if the japanese had only stayed on their
island a member of darby's first ranger
battalion since north africa and thus a
veteran veteran of blazing heat bitter
cold three amphibious landings and more
than a few mountaintop alamos watson and
his echo company platoon had been among
the few groups to reach cisternas outer
outskirts
there with all hope lost watson at just
21 had volunteered to stay behind to
cover his squad's retreat a sacrifice
that resulted in humiliation in the
streets of rome followed by 15 months at
stalag 2b
situated on the northeastern fringe of
the reich and known all above are known
above all for its cruelties
watson had responded to captivity
by murdering the camp commandant's
german shepherd and by attempting so
many escapes that the guards had
nicknamed him the haste
german for rabbit
upon liberation watson had vowed that he
would never be a prisoner again
it was a promise his personality was
only to keep for just five months
whereupon he was jailed for 30 days and
eat in east hartford for inciting a riot
and resisting arrest crimes that
preceded six more similar episodes
breach of peace assault intoxicated
assault and assault and battery of a
police officer
sorry man
this guy is a freaking maniac
for the last charge watson would have
faced as much as nine months in jail
had he not re-enlisted in the army then
volunteered re-volunteered for the
rangers
at that interview for the virginia one
mission mcgee had seen in watson a man
physically distinct from the others at
six feet four 240 pounds a chin heaped
like a fist
hands the size of country hams a reddish
brown cadillac mustache with ends as
sharp as tomahawks
the real difference in watson however
had lain just below his eyebrows a gaze
so comfortable and confident that he
looked 15 years older than his 27 years
suggested
there was only one issue
imposing
experienced eager a preternatural
fighter watson had ended world war ii
with a rank of
t5 technician fifth grade essentially a
corporal
in the five years since he had advanced
not a single rank
a fact that belied his leadership
potential which was ample but spoke
volumes about his exposure to a military
leader's responsibilities from mission
planning to command and control
um
yeah yeah as as you mentioned he ended
up getting captured again
he gets captured again he
not before he manages to get all three
of his uh ranger comrades uh safely
evacuated he uh winds up um
uh
escaping from the mountaintop uh you
know alamo that they fight their way off
of a navy pilot had crashed so it's him
a navy pilot and six uh korean partisans
and they are
uh making their way uh something like 87
miles to the coast and they are not to
the coast to friendly lines
and the navy pilot gets
captured
most of the koreans
get captured only
watson gets captured i think two miles
from friendly lines almost makes it
and the two koreans that do make it back
to friendly lines
they
ultimately are discovered that they had
only made it back
because they agreed to spy for the north
koreans and they are executed
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
on july 27 1953 the armistice that
effectively ended the korean war was
signed and within days the chinese and
north koreans began publishing daily
lists of un prisoners of war earmarked
for release
for a printing press operator at the new
york times who received each list
directly from the front
this initiated a high a nightly series
of breath-holding paper clutching
searches through line after line of
names
not one of them belonging to his son
of whom he had no had had no information
for two years five months and 26 days
so this is watson's old man
yeah
after 32 nights of this routine and
having recently been informed that only
one more list of 110 names remained to
be published this father left his
co-workers and his post behind and made
for the connecticut shore to be alone
there
hours later he was found by local police
and informed that the north koreans had
at the last minute added a hundred and
eleventh name to their final list
a name the local police knew all too
well
in the 29 months since his capture
corporal martin r watson a soldier no
guard or prisoner believed was actually
a corporal had set an example for
captivity that to this day has never
been exceeded
30 days after he was captured for 18 of
which he had been starved in a cave to
make his 240 pound size somewhat easier
to handle watson and a south korean
comrade had knocked out a guard with a
rock and made for the surrounding
mountains where they survived for five
days until their pursuers had disabled
them by rolling a grenade into their
hideout
never medically treated except with some
shreds of brown paper to cover his
wounds watson had nevertheless escaped
again this time by wriggling out of his
rope restraints and jumping free of a
moving truck as it slowed around a bend
this time he survived a week before
inadvertently walking right past a
wide-eyed north korean patrol
for these attempts and one other plus an
attempted suicide with a broken piece of
glass he had been relentlessly beaten
with rifle butts and boot heels and
periodically starved and almost always
isolated once in an unsheltered hole for
72 days with rations described by the
record as sparse
rightly suspected as an oss spy and
saboteur watson had also been subjected
to almost daily interrogation by the
north koreans the chinese even the
russians who had drilled him on his
exposure to the gestapo in world war ii
but especially on the organization's
methods and tactics of the paratroop
unit to which they knew he had belonged
once watson's response to these and
other questions had been a mixture of
stony silence or intentional
contradiction responses that had
invariably earned him a switch across
the eyes a pistol barrel across the face
or hours of kneeling with his nose
pressed against a wall and a stone on
his head
throughout these deprivations watson
never lost his bearing nor conviction
once standing during a packed camp
lecture by a british speaker from the
london daily worker
to say that he quote didn't know what
communism was and didn't care to find
out
end quote nor did he and his fellow pows
want to listen to this trainer commie
son of a
for this affront
and as his example to other prisoners he
was eventually frog marched before a
military tribunal informed of the
armistice then sentenced to death by
firing squad he still didn't talk
in the end after having been starved
from 240 pounds
to 120 pounds
his was an example that earned him the
final distinction as the second to last
u n p o w to be released across the
freedom bridge
on the other side he learned that the
rangers he had so steadfastly protected
from exposure
no longer existed
i have a hard time listening to that
part about his dad still i found that uh
newspaper article and i
but
i don't think any
any dad can read that without
getting choked up
um
but not just that i mean every
i mean the all 750 pages of that
document it was all there and you just
do your best to compress compress
compress get it get as much in there as
possible because nobody else is writing
about this guy you know that you i mean
at least i suspected you know this guy's
lost to history
um
well last time we you were on and we
talked about this actually the first
time you were on we talked about this i
said that's the next book right like
take those 750 pages get it down let's
chop it down to you know 500.
yeah there's
there'd be problems to do that but i
think what would be the problems because
i'll just go and vote photocopy that
thing you know right there it's the the
way that the documents are lined out
it's a each one of these things or each
of that 750 pages
all of these are uh most of the things
in there are interviews with inmates
other roommates other inmates and
there's no like chronology to them so
what i've done which is a
i mean it's kind of a wrap up or or like
a montage of things that's the best i
could do uh
considering the timeline that i had
available to me
um
but what else is not in there i mean the
i mean the the entire epitaph for for
martin watson is you know what comes
what comes after the war and that's
you know what comes after the war for so
many of these guys you know i've talked
to you know
a number of his
you know family members um and
it's it's tragedy i mean
though he survives the war and you know
he comes back and uh i mean
he's honored you know he's um
not sufficiently i don't think i mean if
there's anybody in the book that you
know is a deserving uh military member
of the medal of honor it's watson
i think he was he received right i know
he received a silver star for that which
i think is completely insufficient
um but what happens after the fact is
you know he comes back to a wife comes
back and he has children and he's not
capable of managing that um
ultimately he is
because of his demons he leaves his
family uh escapes to
alaska and you know works on a an oil
pipeline for years
only sees his son i think uh like
two dozen times uh and you know after uh
he leaves
um
gets cancer
and dies i think when his son is about
12 years old
one of the last memories that his son
has of him is in the hospital bed and
he's completely he shrunk from you know
this you know monster of a man that he
used to be into you know
this uh emaciated figure uh and every
time his son would come to the hospital
to see his dad
his dad the the password that he had to
knock or he that he had to give before
he came into the hospital room was
courage
so
again um
unbelievable detail in here um
although you did you did mention there's
a a raid
that you've cut from the book
yeah the witch on damn on the way john
damn what was that all about so the
huichon dam raid is um
it's another you know failed attempt
it's it's probably the one
um
if
if the virginia one raid wasn't uh
wasn't the raid that would have
convinced army planners that uh you know
the rangers had a purpose to play in
this in this conflict uh than it was the
the way chan dam raid and that was a
um
it was happening almost at the exact
same time as the
as the virginia one team was escaping
south
along the peninsula
uh but it was um
it was a uh
it was
not well planned uh but it was a was
supposed to be a raid on uh to seize a
dam from the north koreans or from the
from the chinese that were holding it
and they had to row across a lake they
they had to collect you know what uh
what
little uh boats that the army had uh i
mean within 24 hours they threw this
thing together and the rangers had to
paddle secretly across land on an enemy
shore and then climb up a mountain uh to
try and get around this dam
and
in the process of that they're
contacted by a sort of a readout you
know uh that was positioned well away
from the dam they didn't even get close
to the dam so before you know the
morning is even out uh they can't uh
they can't retreat they can't advance
they can't receive supplies um
eventually they are uh
another force comes and relieves them
and rescues them but the raid itself is
uh is a disaster it's not until later
that uh
the dam is actually um uh pummeled by uh
navy um navy uh fighter player fighter
bombers that the the raid is uh
dismantled or taken
um
but that was the one raid i thought you
know if if i couldn't do the virginia
one raid and i couldn't show how the
army you know had turned its back again
on this raider concept and it would have
been the wage on dam raid um it's it
it's you know equally you know dramatic
and it's equally important um
it's just one of those things you have
to make a choice as you know as a
historian what are you going to focus on
you've got to you know keep moving your
reader into the next you know you don't
want to just jam them up in korea you
got to keep keep moving forward so
and so ultimately we end up
leaving the korean war with still no
real
commando unit correct and um
moving in
past the past the korean war into
chapter nine
arleigh burke the bay of pigs
and the launching of the navy's limited
war seals
and i'm going to the book on this
proposed as separate and distinct from
the fleet's udts
the recruits for the new
for the two new seal teams one on each
coast would like adam's rib
be drawn from them
10 officers and 50 enlisted men per team
all graduates of the training first
conceived for the scouts and raiders
then modified by kaufman for the ncdus
the specialized training needed to
create the seals said the memo
would occur at existing army and navy
schools or could be added to the present
udt curriculum as required
before long rumors of a naval commando
unit began to hover so thickly above the
udts that many took the clouds for smoke
of their own making
it would require another six months of
cno level conversations meetings and
memoranda to allocate funding to carve
out basing to hammer out organizational
plans and chains of command to purchase
commercial watercraft and fun new
research for silent motors to resurrect
six mothball mothballed apds from
retirement to study the country of south
vietnam and there to embark on a type of
riverine warfare said one memo that the
navy had not seriously attacked since
the war between the states
and at the end of that six months
the navy would quietly without any
ceremony
commission seal team one on coronado
island in san diego and seal team two at
little creek in virginia beach
so this is we're starting to get to that
culminating point
yeah they um
i mean the
i mean you touch on the controversy
there let me see
there's this whole period
after
the seal teams are created
where
guys start coming out of the woodwork to
say this was my idea i did this i'm the
one that wrote the memo all right let's
see it
let's see the memo
you know uh roy baum who was uh
he wrote an entire book called the first
seal i mean he
makes the case that it was him that put
this thing together and he based you
know his idea uh in part off of uh mary
miles's book a different kind of war a
different kind of war didn't come out
for five years after
after when the seal teams were created
to use mary miles is like
his book is the anyway
um
but yeah i mean there's uh oops yeah
but you know it's
this whole thing
because none of this would have happened
without like we talked about in the the
last episode not without the effort
without the foresight of
burke and
um
you know there were lots of uh lots of
you know folks in in the udts that
they had no interest in going in this
direction there were some that did i
mean there was a there was a contingent
of folks and and like i talked about
fielding boynton uh atchison there were
guys that had uh experienced those uh
you know those raids in the korean war
and they knew that there was something
the more that they could be doing um but
i don't think anybody in the udts was
proposing this this this uh this this
force this go anywhere for us uh i mean
and
the idea that this would be a go
anywhere for us it's it's there in the
in the original name
i mean nobody had really thought that
you know they were going to be creating
this capture kill commando force but
they had thought of that go anywhere
capability and that's there from the
beginning that c
air land capability
and that was all derived from uh
this series of uh committees and um uh
you know memoranda
and meetings that burke had convened
with his senior staffers and they had
pulled that from all the ideas they'd
been collecting from the fleet they'd
been interviewing and talking and
having people write white papers
and just develop ideas and
i mean
the one you know genius of burke is that
he realizes he's not a genius he's
pulling ideas from every place he can
possibly get them so when you know these
guys say that it was my idea you know
i'm not necessarily you know so
confident that they didn't you know send
these memoranda we just don't have them
we don't i mean
there's only one person who's
responsible for that you know final
establishment that's him
him
burke
the strange thing about this is
you know when you say well there's a lot
of udt guys that were sort of like hey
we don't want to do that
and
if you were to if you were to ask
probably the entire time that i've been
that i was in the seal teams up until
today
the percentage of people that
if you gave them the choice of what type
of
operation they wanted to conduct yeah
right
i know you know where i'm going right
like everyone would would say
hey
we want to be on land we want to push
another land we want to push into the
hinterland we want to it's is it cool to
come over the beach hell yeah it is it's
awesome but we want to go over the beach
we want to get from the water to the
land
that's where the the cool things are
happening
uh it's interesting to think that
it's it's interesting to think that you
would
back in the day
like i knew if it wasn't if it wasn't
for the seal teams if i didn't see
pictures of
freaking guys dressed up like commandos
with machine guns in vietnam i never
would have joined the navy ever
not in a million years if you had only
seen a picture of a guy in swim trunks
with a dive knife yeah i mean yeah it
was that is
yeah what is that what are you doing i
don't know but the thing is like
everybody who you know joined the seal
teams in that era that's what they were
joining for they weren't joining because
of the seal teams nobody knew what the
seal teams were it wasn't until you know
they got there and they're like oh
there's this other thing yeah like mike
thornton tommy norris pete peterson bob
gallagher they didn't join the seal
teams they joined they joined the udts
you want to be udt's yeah and
you know regardless they they created
this institution
the other thing that's interesting about
this is
when you think about the senior
leadership
in the in the navy including burke
being on a ship
off the coast
unless you're in world war ii and you're
getting attacked by kamikazes being in a
ship off the coast of combat is
is
totally it's a world away
if you're in a ship off the coast of a
combat zone you are a world away from
combat like i said unless you're in
world war ii and there's freaking
kamikazes coming at you god bless you
but if you're not in world war ii or
whatever this next war is going to be or
whatever this next war is going to be
possibly
uh
yeah you're you're you're in a different
scenario so it's interesting to think
that
that the that the
senior leadership thought let us get
involved in that let us the navy get
involved in that stuff over there
over the horizon onto the land where
there's bullets and bad guys and snakes
right it's
you would think part of the navy would
say hey look that's not really our
business that's not our thing we're
staying on our lane over here we'll get
you to the beach you take it from there
so
if it wasn't for this void that the navy
had seen over and over and over again
where they couldn't get someone to do
what we needed him to do
the navy couldn't get commandos to do
what they needed commandos to do
anybody could have stepped into this
role anybody could have and and uh um
when when i uh look back and and you
know you can almost use the uh uh
example of aviation uh as as a counter
to my you know whole thesis you could
say like um well you know just because
you know the army and the marine corps
had failed to do this doesn't mean the
navy wouldn't have you know uh you know
uh
done this as well i mean you could have
had the rangers uh you could have had
the green berets you could have had all
these entities and the navy still would
have created the seal teams and i say
that's i don't think so and and the
reason i
i think that that's wrong is because of
all these episodes of the navy uh
attempting to partner time and time
again like the navy is is constantly
saying
we will support you we will just let us
partner with something stop you know
taking this away from us because all
through the korean war all through world
war ii you know the navy is sponsoring
various commando units
so i don't i mean i i think that
argument um
it's not an argument that's been made
back to me but it was always an argument
that i was thinking about when i was
writing this book like to confirm you
know to to sort of you know means test
my my own thesis like none of this would
have happened without that neglect but
it also would not have happened without
that um
uh
with without that mentality uh that
burke had
so it's a combination of two things you
know it was yes it was the neglect of
the army in the marine corp but it was
also you know not just neglect it didn't
just create that space it was also you
know you have this person who's um you
know this this person of burke who you
know can't stomach a navy
that is not connected to combat
and if those two things hadn't collided
there would not be a seal teams
here's a
hypothesis
and i don't know
how this is going to land
but i'm taking a shot at it
the water
sucks for operations
it completely sucks for operations it
ruins your weapons it ruins your radios
it makes you cold
it it can kill you
the water absolutely sucks for
operations
and
throughout all of these opportunities
for all these other units to say hey we
got this i
it seems like at least it might have
been a little bit of a factor just a
little tiny bit of a factor
for everybody
when the big navy says hey we need
somebody that can stay in the water and
also go up on that everyone goes hey
we'll just take the land part over here
like we'll give it a try but then damn
that sucked we were freezing our weapons
didn't work uh we lost two guys that
drown
right that's what happens and there's no
enemy there yeah yeah that's like
whatever you want to do back there
i mean
yeah there's some things that maybe you
want us to blow up from time to time and
you know you may want us to figure out
how deep the water here is but you know
the
i mean i a lot of us just you know the
you know like that you know the whole
the whole um
gap of the animals or the revolt of the
admirals i mean they want to prove
they're relevant everybody wants to be
relevant
and and institutions are just
collections of people and you know
institutions are going to
make themselves relevant whether it's in
the market or with government agencies i
mean we are we're gonna find
opportunities or you're gonna if there
are no opportunities you're gonna make
them
and
um
you're not i mean everybody wants to
earn their paycheck and feel like
they've done something
i mean if there's nothing to do
well you're gonna find it yeah i'm gonna
find something
um
you talked about burke's uh cno ceremony
a little bit when we kicked this thing
off i mean
were you gonna yeah what else were you
gonna say about that uh the whole
chapter had started i found uh i
actually found uh
burke's cno ceremony on youtube i don't
know how many times i watched it i mean
i don't like i don't know this is when
he became cno yeah there's a that's on
youtube that's on youtube damn and i
mean i think there's you know uh 500
views i'm responsible for 485.
um how long is it it's like well i mean
they they compress it it's like
i think there's a couple of different
versions of it but uh
maybe
30 minutes okay but there's different
speakers and everything and i'm i'm
watching this thing like time after time
i remember watching this thing like you
know in the middle of night like
you know i'm not doing anything bad i'm
watching i'm watching 50 year old uh
navy cno
did he give a powerful speech or
something no his speech is terrible
he's not a good speaker he's sort of
choppy
there's a couple other speakers that get
up in the process that are actually
they're that are better than him so why
are you so hyped on this thing that you
watched it 499 times you know i think a
lot of it was just because i mean you
know some of the things that are said
you know they're talking about this you
know this revolution uh that's that's
undergoing uh with naval warfare that's
about to you know undergo with naval
warfare uh and when when burke gets up
he articulates sort of you know his
ideas and you know so many of his ideas
are you know uh
the the navy's at the cusp of this
technological revolution and so when
burke comes into office my you know any
any person who listened to that speech
would think all right well the navy is
going to evolve uh they're going to go
deeper they're going to go further up
they're going to uh you know start
taking advantage of nuclear weapons it's
going to be a technological revolution
uh in the navy
and that's where it will stop but that's
not what happens burke's
burke's interest
burke's emphasis does not stop he yes he
he modernizes the fleet he takes he puts
nuclear weapons on submarines
he he stretches the navy's reach from
you know the bottom of the ocean to the
edge of the atmosphere
but in between that gap
he also does a lot of things you know i
think the most consequential
is the establishment of this unit
and
you wouldn't have predicted that or you
would not have seen
you know a uh
um
he would not have you know conveyed any
plans like that in that that
presentation so or that initial speech i
was so i was watching it not just for
what was said but what for what was not
said how much credit are you giving to
kennedy in this whole gig so kennedy so
there's a lot of you know old frog men
that you meet um
who uh
they still think that uh the seal teams
would not exist without kennedy um it's
a really com
apparently compelling you know myth i
don't know why because you know kennedy
dies in november of 63. the seal teams
are established in january of 62. and if
there's anything that we learn you know
in the preceding chapters of this book
is that you know all of these units you
know
they they could have been you know
killed in the crib you know they could
have you know strangled to death in in
infancy or smothered you know by a
pillow as how i describe it like these
all these units could have been you know
disbanded i mean the seal teams are only
two years old at the time of kennedy's
death so even if kennedy had been
responsible and i don't think he is
because uh all of the
committees that burke has convened
before kennedy's even elected you know
they proceed you know they proceeded his
election they're already mentioning you
know the word seal before kennedy is
elected they have these plans already in
place
um kennedy's supportive of them um but
he's not the he's not the reason that
they're
um put into place yeah some some of
kennedy's speeches
you know he's talking about
unconventional warfare he's talking
about all these commando type things and
he wants everybody to get involved in
this he does but the navy was um
the navy is already forward leaning into
this i mean
the army too the army i mean and and
when kennedy comes in you know his um
you know he has a love affair with the
the concept of you know counter
insurgency and
his favorite you know unit of all time
which is the army special forces
but uh
yeah i think i i've read a speech of his
at west point that's real actually i've
read it on this podcast because it's
sort of sort of how
it it indicates so much the whole idea
of the special forces and special
operations and how big it's going to be
for him
uh what about going as you're trying to
research the bay of pigs you know you
got the cia was there
how available is information about that
it's a black hole
to this day huh this day i don't know
how many requests i made to the the
cia's archives uh for information i
would find you know a thing here or
there but not not very much
um
their i was able to find uh several of
the frogmen that participated in the bay
of pigs i was writing
um up until the final days uh
before the publisher literally you know
ripped the book out of my hands i was i
was talking to um
korean frogman or a
cuban frogman um
and you know found one i couldn't
believe i found him uh interviewed him
and then he gave you know me a number
for another guy couldn't believe you
know he did and i talked to him gave me
a number for another one before i knew
it i was talking to all these guys i was
like oh my gosh this is incredible
didn't never expected you know to to
find any of these you know covert
operatives but you know here they are
and they wanted to tell their story so
it was pretty cool
awesome um so we get through
that time anything else you want to
cover in that chapter
oh i mean you could no i think
graystone lynch and and rip robertson i
mean these are
these and these are guys that you cut
i didn't cut them they're in the book i
mean they they they could be their own
yeah they could be their own books i
mean they're both you know they're
they're both the cia um you know uh not
case officers they're the paramilitary
officers that are leading um
not just the the reconnaissance not just
the cuban frogmen or the raid that the
cuban frogmen do
but they're also
running the entire um
uh
the the the mission they're they're back
on ships uh you know relaying
information doing everything they can to
support uh the invasion they're held you
know back and then when
the
brigade forces collapse
both robertson and lynch they spend two
weeks sleeping almost not at all
doing everything they can to rescue as
many brigade survivors as they can
so when they finally do
get pulled uh or when they finally do
get pulled and the navy's supporting
that entire effort the navy doesn't
support uh the the initial raid almost
at all despite uh burke's repeated
protests in his uh repeated attempts to
get kennedy to to let the navy intervene
um but the navy uh does not abandon uh
the the cuban uh brigade members they
uh night after night the navy sending
whale boats ashore
do anything they can to rescue survivors
and the most compelling
characters in the whole testimony that
our robert kennedy
convenes in the aftermath of these two
guys when they they show back up
to testify
in front of this committee and they're
they're completely sunburned black
almost
they show up in boots that are salt that
are crusted white with salt water i mean
they're pretty uh
pretty convincing
and and grayson lynch uh you know he
goes to his grave you know uh hating
anything you know
remotely related to kennedy
he goes on to another career he was in
omaha beach uh he was at omaha beach he
became it was a green beret he joins the
cia i think he ends his government
service with the dea he starts the dea
if you believe it
that brings us up to uh chapter 10
which is titled
kennedy's army of gladery gladiators and
the counterinsurgency that blunted their
swords then cleared the way for another
contender
echo's getting a kick out of that one
and
you you know you talk about the fact
that this was a really hard chapter
chapter for you to write
um and you
this is this is the and it makes sense
that it's hard to write because you've
got the special forces yeah which
by all means look if the marine corps
isn't going to make some kind of a
maritime special operations go anywhere
for us then
if the if the marine corps is not going
to do that
then certainly the army special forces
should become
this capability
and it's a very bizarre bizarre is a
strong word it's a very interesting
thing that drives them in a different
direction right
yeah i i mean it's totally unpredictable
i mean they they create them in 1952
sort of right after the failure of the
virginia one raid but they see the
potential of partisans or they see the
potential of guerrilla forces i mean uh
the one disadvantage that the west has
uh compared to the communist uh forces
of the soviet union are you know we
don't have as many men we just don't
have the manpower so
or at least in the in the military we
don't so uh our idea or the the idea of
special forces is to be able to you know
parachute you know behind enemy lines
and raise a guerrilla force to uh raid
the enemy's vulnerable spaces
the problem that they you know discover
in this period between 1952 and 1962 is
that the soviet union is not like other
countries it's not like the west if you
want to you know create a partisan force
in central colorado you might be able to
do it you might be able to find some you
know wingnuts out there and raise a
militia and you know go attack you know
oil plants or whatever you could
probably do that because we have an open
society that's gonna say that does
happen yeah right
yeah but you know you can't do that in
uh in a uh
in a gestapo state or a soviet union
because they know they've got identity
cards on everybody i mean you can't
um there's just not there's not the
infrastructure to be able to do that so
the special forces you know have you
know this idea that you're going to have
behind the lines raiders made up of
indigenous forces it's ridiculous
so um they
sense that they know that and they start
to
um uh you know evolve themselves they
transform themselves into a completely
sort of different unit which kennedy
finds out about or is sort of you know
these two things are sort of happening
at the same time kennedy is discovering
this concept of counter insurgency and
uh the winning of hearts and minds and
the uh the at least if not uh
um the creation of uh american freedom
fighters at least denying uh tribesmen
and uh indigenous peoples to the soviets
so why don't we support these people why
don't we you know give them weapons why
don't we train them how to fight um and
it becomes you know the perfect you know
marriage of a capability and an
opportunity
counter insurgency and the special
forces so
they're married together and that leads
us into vietnam
yeah the the
transition these guys started off
where they started you know in the early
1950s
um
it looks like they could end up just
being a good commando force or a
straight up commander absolutely i mean
i'm going to the book here you say
established in 1952 the special forces
had been intended to replicate the
experiences of its founder and first
commander former oss operative colonel
aaron bank in 1944
as a 41 year old jedburgh he had dropped
into france led resistance fighters then
in 1945 as improper as it sounds had
almost led an operational group of
german pows into the alps on a mission
to capture hitler
hell yeah
guided by these examples bank and
successors had erected an an
organization to match their mission two
thousand airborne qualified soldiers
spread across three forward staged
battalion sized groups one in okinawa
one in germany one in fort bragg north
carolina already at a moment's notice to
drop into an enemy country and lead a
ready band of resistance fighters to
physically create these groups a special
warfare center had been hacked out of a
remote corner of fort bragg in the
mid-1950s and volunteers had been
recruited plenty of former rangers old
jockstrap type commandos
no first enlistments or second
lieutenants permitted to apply the and
ushered through a three-month course in
guerrilla warfare with a staggering 90
dropout rate this was followed by
language instruction and individual
courses in one of four specialties
weapons demolition radio communications
and longest of all medicine the pipeline
culminated with a multi-week exercise in
which candidates infiltrated a note a
notional enemy country linked up with a
band of dissidents which were other can
candidates sent up a hinterland base
camp imparted their individual
specialties and then led their
guerrillas on a series of raids and
ambushes all while avoiding aggressor
force of local deputies national
guardsmen and state police
there you go man
that's special forces i mean that's uh
what is it robin sage it's robin sage
yeah it's it
and they still have it and they
you know still the idea is that you're
going to be able to uh lead or find
these groups i think that's the that's
the that's the trick is how do you find
these groups in
you know soviet societies or societies
where you know you have a an aggressive
uh you know you know gestapo type police
force you you don't have a free society
like and the only place that you're
going to find you know a ready pool of
candidates to you know join a thing like
this is in um you know
sort of ungoverned spaces where there
aren't
you know these
uh
you know
state police or secret police
what's the deal with yarbrough's
daughter
oh it's one of the you know things that
i i was uh
so yarbrough he he's the um
it was tough to find the character in
this i always try to
you know
when i was working on a chapter working
on a different unit i was always trying
to find you know one you know the
operation that was um you know most
consequential to driving you know that
mission's either success or failure
their their
continuation their disbandment but then
once i found the the operation or the
the program or something i was always
trying to find the character uh that was
most important to that mission successor
failure um and
yarbrough
this this chapter is distinct in one way
it's not there's no operation i'm
covering lots of little mini battles i
mean war is changing at this point so
you know the
sort of the
um uh the the the chapter structure that
i had settled on world war ii and the
korean war you know where i focus on one
main uh operation it's kind of gone at
this point in the book because you know
there's no one there's so many battles
that are occurring are so many little
small skirmishes but you know i focus on
yarbrough because he's the person who
um he creates the special warfare center
or the the schoolhouse for green berets
and and marries uh you know the green
berets to this uh this new um
uh operation of counterinsurgency so
there's no more commando operations for
the special forces no raiding or
anything like that it's only coin or
counter insurgency so he's training guys
not to just you know
lead ambushes and things like that but
he's teaching his guys to uh dig wells
and you know how you know animal
husbandry and how do you how do you
convince you know tribal people you know
to to join your your group you have to
you know you've got to do med checks
you've got to do all the sorts of things
that nobody really likes to do
um
but in the course of him you know
overhauling the special warfare center
and in the course of him preparing to
showcase this to kennedy for kennedy's
visit to fort bragg
his daughter who's about to
get married
to another green beret officer
she's in a terrible car accident and
dies
she's killed
and uh
yarbrough is a month away from you know
his you know career-making
um
uh presidential visit uh this is going
to you know this visit is going to
either make or break the the special
forces everything that he's worked for
um and in that period he
like i write in the book he cinches down
his grief and he gets back to work the
first thing he does and i managed to
talk to um
i interviewed yarbrough's daughter's
fiancee he never married uh after uh she
was killed
um
she would uh
but he said the first thing that he did
and he talked to
the the general several times after uh
his fiancee was killed but the first
thing that yarbo
yarbrough did after his wife died is the
same day he went through the house and
he took down every picture of her you
mean after his daughter died after his
daughter died he went through the house
yarbo did and he took down every picture
got rid of every trace of her couldn't
handle the grief
shut he just shut it down
and then he
spent the next month doing everything he
could he poured himself into
getting ready for that presentation
and yarborough drove the special forces
as you just said into
not being a commando force but being a
counterinsurgency force right which
creates another gap which which leaves
the gap the gap remains the gap remains
um
now we end up with
chapter 11.
the first seals their search for a
mission and the report that found it for
them
the buckley report
what's going on
so
um in 1964 the navy
the navy's seeing that there is you know
trouble in
southeast asia and wants to contribute
but does not know how the navy is run by
traditional
blue water sailors as it always is
um
and
is trying to figure out how to
contribute to this you know conflict and
they um
they gather together uh
seven uh seven naval officers led by a
uh
a blue water sailor admiral savage
they
send this survey team to vietnam to you
know get a lay of the land and figure
out how the navy can contribute
it's uh
the group itself is you know comprised
of a lot of the navy's kind of
unconventional thinkers
um uh david del judis who is the first
commanding officer of seal team one uh
he's there he's sort of acting as a
contributor
admiral's aide
there's a former udt officer a silver
star winner
and there's
phil bucklew and
several others who have spent
considerable time in vietnam so vil phil
bucklew
at this point is he he's a captain or an
he's the second in command
they're there for less than a week when
admiral savage has a i'm not sure the
record is unclear he has either a heart
episode or he um
he gets into an alcohol related incident
and is forced to
retire back to the states
regardless it leaves phil buckley in
charge of the survey team now what would
have happened if admiral savage had uh
remained in his position as the uh as
the survey leader i don't know but what
we do know is what did happen and that's
phil butler who was the
um the most um
uh forward-leaning or
um
uh
you know he the the person who's still
in the military who has uh experienced
every unconventional of phase of the
navy's sort of inland adventurism he's
now in charge of this uh this survey
team
they spend six weeks you know going
around the entire country they go to
special forces camps
they travel up the mekong river
they examine uh where
supplies are coming in if they are
as the navy is contending or as the navy
argues that they're being sailed down
around the coast and infiltrated
along along the the ocean coast
and what they figure out is that none of
that is happening none of the the navy's
claims are are true
all of the
contraband all the weapons that are
being funneled to the insurgency are
coming right down that mekong river and
they're being
injected
throughout the country through various
waterways
he discovers this
and says we are not going to have an
impact
if the navy
doesn't leave blue water uh and starts
doing what uh uh the fleet did in the
american civil war and that's hitting
hitting the brown water rivers
um
and it in the report you know he makes a
point to say that you know there's lots
of opportunities for raiding along these
rivers he only mentions the seals once
never really connects them to that idea
rating
but he he does you know say
explicitly in the report
um
the navy
should be in charge
of that inland raiding
mission
and when the report's delivered
it's sort of uh
you know the whole process of this like
everybody's trying to get a hold of his
report before he uh uh uh
publishes it before he uh takes it back
to the navy uh paul harkins who's in
charge of uh macv at the time uh his
deputy william westmoreland they're all
trying they're having lunch with him
henry cabot lodge is the uh
the ambassador to vietnam everybody's
trying to get a look at phil buckler's
report phil buckley to his credit he
does not want to let this thing out of
his hands until he has a chance to let
his uh navy superior see it first it's
uh you know it's still controversial
like
you know the the navy like i said the
navy had been involved in a war like
that for
uh over for over a hundred years um so
you're saying it's controversial be
because of that it's controversial
because he's advocating for
you know this this uh this riverine
force this uh this force that's going to
take us away from the blue water away
from you know the navy's emphasis at
that point which is aircraft and air
care and aircraft carriers and um kind
of nuclear subs and everything like that
you're you're you're
putting us back in the weeds um but
having been uh you know the uh
a veteran of the scouts and raiders uh
and then a veteran of saco and then a um
in charge of the navy's
relationship with the cia during the
korean war and all the various cia raids
with the udts in the korean war i mean
he is he's positioned i mean he's
he's taking his biography and he's
saying well why shouldn't we be doing
this
i've experienced two wars where we've
done this already uh we we absolutely
should be trying to support this effort
as much as possible if the if the
government or if the country has decided
this is worth american lives then it
should be um it should be a mission
worth uh
navy lives as well
and he delivers that report to just
admiral feld
and the commander-in-chief of the
pacific fleet they're they're
head over heels in love with this thing
no
they're not head over heel they they
this report gets
passed back and forth i mean it becomes
like i said in the book it becomes a bit
of a hot potato where does it get
traction
uh it all i'm not sure where it
ultimately gets traction uh because it
takes two years for really the navy to
you know put this thing into effect
before they field you know the navy
riverine force or ctf-116 combined task
force 160. was there a champion for it
above
phil h buckley not that i could find um
interesting but everybody uh
um
i if if i had to guess i would guess it
was probably somebody like norville
norvell ward who becomes more important
later
but i'm not sure i didn't find him
one other part of this chapter that i
wanted to run through because it's
pretty freaking awesome
is this uh at some point the navy sends
down some some uh
uh like academics and some some
psychologists
and so so i gotta read this part
when the navy's academics had arrived in
1955 to observe udt training their
purpose had been to validate the
course's individual selection tests
the soft sand runs the ocean swims the
harassments of hell week and short of
invalidating any of these to develop
what they called realistic selection
standards that would reduce what the
navy admitted was the course's excessive
attrition
subjecting students to a battery of
personality tests and classifying their
individual traits
age education intelligence and so on the
academics hopes not only to predict the
candidate's likelihood of success in
training but also his success in an
actual underwater demolition team
in the course of these assessments they
learned that the students below the age
of 21 were eight percent more likely to
fail
roughly the same rate as high school
dropouts
while students from broken homes were
just as likely to graduate as anyone
else
based on the number of times a student
had volunteered to visit the dispensary
which is medical assessors determined
that a candidate in moderate health who
minimized the psychological importance
of pain fatigue and intense discomfort
stood a much higher chance of success
than
quote the most physically fit who were
over concerned about their injuries
so you're better off just being a tough
son of a that maybe can't run too
quick but i don't care if my knee hurts
i'm gonna keep going
the least common traits among successful
frogmen seem to be restraint
thoughtfulness
sociability
and cautiousness
the most common were responsibility
emotional stability original thinking
objectivity and most of all masculinity
so you know as i read through that i
mean it just you just
picture every team guy that you know and
you know where the bell curve is
and
yeah i mean i
i had a
i knew that this had to get in the book
i bounced it around from section to
section right because i had about you
know 15 years you know to play with i
finally you know found a home for it
here and i was i was really happy that i
did there's lots of these little like
assessments that they had put together
over the years and they were trying to
like understand and they still try and
understand they still they still do and
they still have no idea no idea
uh that's that's why it's so great
because it's just i mean
this is a report done in 1955. we're
still at this we still have no like the
navy still says hey why can't you figure
out who's gonna make it why is your
attrition rate so high they still said i
mean the attrition rate right now is
insane in buds it didn't say like
10 15 percent
are making it through it continues on
later studies had gone on to test a
variety of variables including the
benefits of wheat germ in a student's
diet which proved predictive predictably
negligible
and a series of rorschach tests and
psychiatric interviews to determine the
effect of sexuality on a candidate's
success or failure
successful frogmen said the sex report's
author appeared to require this specific
rather masculine and adventurous
occupation with all of its
self-destructive and masochistic
implications
because and this was just the author's
speculation of their magical attraction
to the depth of the sea and the security
of the womb and an unconscious
motivation to prove their masculinity
coupled with a fear of involvement with
women
setting aside the psychoanalyst tendency
to project their own insecurities onto
their subjects the navy had not been
able to argue with the udt's results
that was not the worst dig i got one in
there
i have never met a group of more
self-reliant hell for leather
characters wrote reporter bill stapleton
after accompanying a udt to saint thomas
in the virgin islands in 1955.
besides their typical
reconnaissance exercise
exercises submarine lockouts and test
with miniature submersibles the frogmen
had also
salvaged a 50-foot yacht from a reef
twisted the tails of passing sharks and
when an american sailor had disappeared
into the harbor on a moonless night had
commandeered a truck roared to the
wharf's edge and as if they'd been
scouting the contours of an enemy beach
dove online until they found the drowned
man
in their free time they spearfished
drank untold amounts of beer erected
beachside bonfires and in overflowing
pots of sea water
and vinegar boiled lobsters and
astonished the superstitious natives by
broiling barracuda steaks
you eat barracuda barracuda eat you they
had said
promises replied a frog man nothing but
promises
so exclusive were the udts said one
observer that even rank meant nothing to
them
when seen in their standard swim trunks
and belt knives surrounded by charts and
diving equipment and asked by passerby
if they were indeed in the navy the
frogmen would invariably reply
regardless of the asker's rank nope
we're all in udt
[Laughter]
uh
so there you go
i went to st thomas one time did you
yeah and it sounds about like this
we rented a room so we were doing
training in puerto rico
and i think we got
we got
a little we chartered a plane and bro
this is like 1990 whatever i mean this
is not when you people are chartering
planes i don't know who pulled this
together we chartered a plane we go to
saint thomas
we get there that place is beautiful by
the way
but we rent we've got an 18 man we're
we're an arg platoon we've got an 18-man
platoon so i'm pretty sure everyone went
but most of us went we got a bunch of
guys most of the platoon we rent one
hotel room
for everyone to stay in because you know
we're all cheap and besides who's
planning on sleeping when we're gonna be
uh long story short when i get back to
the hotel room at seven or eight o'clock
in the morning on saturday morning
there's
all these guys are asleep and i remember
there was someone that had pulled
because there was air conditioning in
the little hotel we were saying so two
guys had pulled the curtains off like
ripped the curtains off the curtain rods
and were rolled up in the curtain rods
like blankets on the floor
like a bunch of just savages
so really not that much has changed
the young udt uh spirit survives
um
and meanwhile this report that you that
you talked about is is circulating and
now we're starting to get some
some traction and
starting to figure out um
what's going on
chapter 12
which is called
the damn break of conventional war in
vietnam and the following flood of
raiders that failed to beat the navy to
the mekong delta all but one
that's impressive right echo yeah
that's good
let me get into this one a little bit
uh
the cia had already discovered there
were challenges at attempting to break a
wild herd of mustangs these are
vietnamese soldiers that they're trying
to train into wearing a warrior's a war
chariot's yoke the cia's initial
solution to this mustang breaking was as
usual to outsource the job to the us
military's trainers and advisors in this
case however the cia's planners did not
offer the job to their standby pool of
special forces a teams but instead took
a long shot chance on a three-man
element from seal team one a gamble due
to the elements leader a man who had
convinced the cia planners that he was
the equivalent of an entire special
forces a team
he almost was with a boxer's jab that
could part the red sea said one who saw
it and a six foot three inch frame that
could have waded through it
it had been natural to assume that
storekeeper first class robert wagner's
most
likely contribution to the seal teams
would have been in pure pugilistic con
combat
his instincts for it were undeniable
driving a jeep through a macv compound
and passing so close to an army sergeant
that the offended man had taken a swing
at wagner's lieutenant
in the passenger seat
wagner had responded by slamming on the
brakes then beating the sergeant so
savagely that the lieutenant had feared
for the man's life
i never saw anything like that the
lieutenant said later
not an uncommon expression whenever
wagner was around
as one of the only enlisted udtr
graduates of that period to be selected
to skip the mandatory stint and udt for
a direct assignment to a seal team bob
wagner despite a wife and four young
children had predictably risen to become
one of the team's most eager volunteers
for repeat deployments to the ben high
and ldnn
three six-month tours in three years
in his role he had earned a reputation
among superiors that had swung between
the superlatives of perfectionist
advisor and perfect seal reputations he
had cultivated while simultaneously
building a name as a wheeler dealer for
his part ownership of a beachside bar in
da nang called the blue moon
clean cut for a seal even by 1960
standards his face a graph of hard
angles and straight lines below a flat
top deliberately raked to attention his
only physical feature that suggested he
was anything more than a lockstep
conventional were his eyes
hard
focused
a bit like a predator in pursuit of its
prey
and implying a similar pace
dude you're a good freaking writer man
that i mean that's just an awesome
an awesome little uh
little section there so we got the mac
vsog we got force recon going on we got
the lerps we got the pru's
yeah it's a tough one this is a tough
it's a tough uh
period to cover because all the stuff is
happening all simultaneously this is the
one chapter that sort of stands alone in
the uh in all my chapters they don't
focus on one person i focus on you know
four
uh distinct units
probably the most important being the
one you just read bob wagner who is
he is he's a tough character to to
uh compress and to you know
it's it's
it's difficult you know to you know
highlight seals that were
you know standouts or i mean it's a it's
a it's a standout group already i mean
the you know the guys that are selected
from udt
uh to come to the seal teams they're the
they're the best guys in udt
um and then to you know you know figure
out who the best guys in the seal teams
were at this point is is also difficult
but then when you you look at somebody
like wagner who kind of stands above
everybody you know in his
um
one his foresight uh
but his uh his ability to you know
you know use everything all the all the
tools that he has and his personality
everything from
straight force i mean he uh
in the in the course of his um
um creation of the pru camp lots of
different entities come in to try and
steal this from him and he uses a
variety of uh ways to keep them out one
he just threatens to kick their ass
two
he you know like i say in the book he
threatens just you know pack up his bags
and go home which you know convinces the
cia planners to push everybody else
aside uh he he um
uh
so he's
but you know all while he's doing that
while he's building this program that
nobody else is building and he's just i
mean he's running from place to place to
place he's participating in missions
he's conducting rifle range
training himself he's managing his own
bar
um he you know he doesn't i mean he he
created the one bar the blue moon and
nang but he also creates a separate bar
down uh he's like franchise and liquor
places i mean he's like in some sense
he's the you know he's the the 1966
version of jocko
he's just i mean he's completely um
but he's uh
um and you know the whole time he's got
you know family with the five kids you
know back home but he's like he'll come
home for six months he'll deploy for six
months he'll come home for six months i
mean he's just he's relentless and by
this point you know in his career he's
already done six separate tours to
vietnam
like he's
he's incomparable
um
while he's doing that well he's where
did you get most of your information
about him from uh there were a
decent amount of
well he he did a recording
to capture this entire creation he did
it with uh franklin anderson so franklin
anderson was
his commanding officer at seal team one
he finds out uh what wagner has been
doing and um thinks that wagner has been
kind of uh
you know exceeding the boundaries of
what he was been allowed to do
so
wagner
um he sits down with an interviewer that
he commissions himself and he explains
the whole thing he's not going to take
his time to write down everything he did
but he's like you want to talk to me
about this bring an interviewer here and
then you can take the transcript back to
uh anderson and he does it he he trans
the whole thing is recorded he
transcribes the thing and passes it back
to seal team one commander anderson
anderson reads the thing and becomes his
greatest advocate at that point
um so yeah he did break all the rules to
make this happen but he didn't it's a
good little leadership thing sometimes
when you're in a leadership position
and you're watching something happen
from the outside and it looks a certain
way
and it's pretty easy to get caught up
and you don't necessarily even have to
be a leadership position but like you
know let's say you're watching a
different unit you know i'm watching a
marine corps unit see what they're doing
from afar and i think what the hell are
these guys doing
and you if you don't if you're not
careful you can look at someone from a
distance and start to be very judgmental
without actually understanding anything
of that that's going on in the ground
so that's something i always tried to be
very careful of so i was watching a unit
they were doing something that didn't
seem to make sense to me instead of me
going with ben's over there like an
idiot running these operations i would
actually reach out to him
you say hey ben can you explain to me
what's going on it looks like you're
doing some wild stuff can you talk to me
talk me through why it's happening
uh that's a mistake that
that that people make
and you have to be careful of it and
that's a great example of well what do
you do if you think somebody's well what
you should do is go talk to them go find
out what's going on and you know what
maybe you do see something that maybe i
do say hey ben you start telling me how
you're doing it i say hey you might want
to think about this and you go that's a
good point you know or maybe i say oh
wow i i understand now what you are you
know we had a little bit of this with uh
doing daytime operations in ramadi
uh
why the hell are seals doing daytime
operations and it's
like i could completely understand
someone thinking that right what are you
doing why are you giving up your
advantage of doing operations at night
when we have night vision and the enemy
doesn't
hey that's a great point here's the
thing we are our our actual mission
tasking from the siege sotif is to train
and fight company and platoon-sized
elements of iraqi soldiers
guess what they don't have
night vision
matter of fact
they would have about one flashlight for
every four guys
so taking these guys out in the middle
of the night was dangerous
and
did we do it yes we did we did it
usually
in direct action raids where we could
set up a situation where white light was
okay because we had already
you know set off a breach or whatever
and now we're just clearing buildings or
they're just clearing buildings
but
we we we had to get the in order to
fight these guys in order to get them
out on the battlefield they're gonna
have to do stuff in the day that's part
one part two is
we owned the night and you know who knew
that the enemy knew that and so guess
what the enemy did at night they didn't
do anything at night we'd go out at
night there would be no one out there
literally no one doing anything but as
soon as the day came out as soon as the
sun came up and the call to prayer went
then it was oh
here comes the enemy because they know
that
it's a more even match and now they're
out there moving amongst the civilian
populace too who's also awake and has to
go you know down to the down to the
corner store to grab some uh dates from
the from his neighbor whatever they
start moving around so now the enemy can
move around
with the camouflage of the local
populace
now if i was on the outside seeing what
the hell is task unit bruiser after
doing daytime operations it might not
make sense as soon as you get an
explanation like that it's like okay
okay i get it there's some there's some
reason for this happening so that's a
good lesson
that uh got learned right there if
someone's doing something that seems a
little bit crazy
fi ask them find out ask them why
they're doing it
as it happens uh if we're gonna i mean
franklin anderson is still around like
he's
and he is
he's in his late 90s but he's still
sharp as attack i talked to him
maybe a week ago cool let's get him on
the podcast
he remembers
everything that's awesome he's in
durango colorado
and anytime i call
you have to
you know start leaving a message on the
machine and just start talking because
eventually his wife is going to pick up
and invariably she's going to pick up
and she's like i didn't know who this
was
uh he's in the field you know clearing
cows or something like he's always
working what a beast he's incredible
he's a he's a little guy he's a but he's
i mean he's still
out there and he's still
like if i talk to him if i ask him a
question okay so was this guy at the
team in 1960 no that guy was an e5 in
1960 well he told you he was an e6 no he
was
like how do you know this that's awesome
yeah he's a he's a character but i got
uh so the other answer your other
question about how i got some of this
information about bob wagner i spent a
lot of time talking to all the folks
that he had done this with guy stone
i talked to his son i talked to a lot of
the a lot of the people that were you
know sort of sort of surrounding him at
the time
and he
not only is he uh you know does he build
this pru program
in vietnam but he comes home and he
builds you know sort of the counterpart
to the pru program in the hills um you
know 200 miles away from the ocean uh in
uh the chocolate mountains he you know
he manages to convince um a local real
estate magnate to give him like 1200
acres of mountain territory or mountain
scrub and he overhauls the entire area
names at campmaken um
and then he uh
um
he just creates a mini pru camp to train
guys how to train other people and to
lead them into combat it goes back on
his last deployment
he uh he's killed
and
the navy recognizes uh his contribution
his you know he's a store he dies as a
store keeper first class
which
for any of your listeners a store keeper
first class means he's essentially a
sergeant he's an ee six
staff sergeant staff sergeant right he's
a staff sergeant
and for his contribution for you know
creating the pr you know the navy's
contribution of the pru program for
creating everything he did in the united
states uh the navy awards him a legion
of merit which is a totally like unheard
of award for a first-class petty officer
you know to get a two but the navy
authorizes the v
for valor with it which never happens
so i mean one of the most highest you
know awards that you can get you know
one to a you know a storekeeper first
class seal
um his family who i was able to
interview they
um
his last child was born uh just prior to
his last deployment um there they were
struggling to you know just comprehend
you know their father's uh you know
death and you know not having him
anymore
um the navy contacts them lets them know
that he's going to be you know given
this you know incredible honor
uh
and
the navy asks how if they would like to
come out for the presentation of the the
ceremony um
the wife asks uh the oldest son the
oldest of the the children he's 16 years
old if uh and leaves it in his hands uh
would you like to go out and receive
your dad's award
the son decides
it's too much it says
just mail it
i get it in the mail a couple weeks
later
oh dang
but this chapter is is not just about
the pru's chapters all about the neglect
not the neglect but you know the marine
corps deciding that they aren't going to
fight in the mekong delta and uh the the
marine force recon uh deciding that
they're going to support the special
forces in the on the cidg camps
and then the marine corps deciding well
we don't really it's too risky to have
those guys out there at the cidg camps
we're going to keep them with the
divisions that it's about the the lerps
or the the creation of uh reconnaissance
um
uh troops to support the divisions
whether it's the you know project delta
with the green berets or whether it's uh
the the lerps with the individual
divisions both of these units are you
know they're they look like seals they
probably act like seals uh they um
probably would have had the same sorts
of missions as seals you know in
different parts of the country to go out
find the enemy you know kill them
capture people and bring them back but
you know the emphasis of all the
divisions is to get these main these
these big forces into combat with the
enemy so all they send them these guys
out to do is find the enemy tell us
where he is and we'll send guys to you
i mean it's it doesn't work because you
know it's vietnam and you know small
pockets of enemies you know if you don't
contact them if you don't you know
engage them when they're there they're
gone they're gone they're gone when you
make that
radio call now you got what however long
it's gonna be they're going to be gone
right they're gone
and most important thing about this
whole period is that all of these units
that are created
um they're created in other parts of the
country they leave the one area of the
country that has the most water has the
most uh you know reason for the navy to
be there completely
uh open open for another unit to come in
um
hoping for one unit to come in let's go
to chapter 13.
the derailing of the first direct action
seals in the wrong sat and the
detachment that restored their prospects
go into the book here real quick
when the seals of detachment delta or
debt delta as it was called arrived in
february 1966
they numbered just three officers and 15
enlisted men not much more than a single
enhanced platoon but a platoon so
important to seal aspirations that it
was led by lieutenant james barnes seal
team one's commanding officer
known as a friendly and capable
administrator the ideal sort for forging
partnerships and acquiring in-country
assets barnes was a firm believer in the
seal's traditional interpretation of
direct action and upon arrival set to
gathering intelligence on all the
enemy's command posts radar dishes and
bridges
barnes's problem
these simply did not exist
on a map the 400 or so square miles
worth of rivers and canals of the wrong
sat special zone looked like the
splitting curving
bronchioles seen in the cross section of
a human lung
on the ground this lung was a putrid
tidewater swamp that when flushed left
behind a morass of boots sucking mud
flats and twisted root peninsulas the
high ground of which could mostly be
measured above the water line with a
yardstick
called the evil place by the locals or
the forest of assassins by the americans
and was and known as it as a past
hideout for pirates the wrong sat was by
the time of the seal's arrival
reinforcing all of these reputations
since it was the source of an increasing
number of rocket attacks on saigon plus
riverbank ambushes along saigon's main
shipping channel
so there you go
here comes this guy barnes rolling in
like hey we know we're going to do we're
going to take out their radar positions
we're going to take out their bridges
that's what we're going to do where are
they they don't exist it's not that kind
of war
i mean this i mean
you know the example that you just used
about you know getting to ramadi and you
know expecting to contact the enemy at
night and do everything like the one
thing that i've learned about frogmen or
at least you know the this modern you
know interpretation of them is
they're going to adapt to find the enemy
and this is one instance where we don't
and we we almost or the the seal teams
almost you know got uh turned turned
away at the front door you know barnes
comes in like you said he you know he
finds that there's nothing that they've
trained for
and their and his response you know not
not really you know not not having ever
done this before and not having you know
any real um
you know playbook you know to to work
from
he decides you know we're we're this
isn't for us
um
and uh
the
uh a series of liberty incidents ensue
and the navy is ready you know kick the
uh the kick the seals out of the country
one you're not you're not engaging the
enemy like we expected you to and two
you're causing problems so uh what what
do you want so they turned you know to
the commander of all the
uh
seals and country who just so happens to
be the person responsible for putting
them there phil bucklow
and they
they present this whole problem to them
buckloo
appeals to uh the commander of macvees
uh understanding of the naval tradition
of leadership
change the leader you're going to change
the rest of the organization so barnes
is removed
after buckley's intercession and an
entire new detachment replaces uh
delta that is debt golf and debt golf
the commander of debt golf is a
junior officer by the name of
maynard wires
comes in and
completely overhauls what the seals are
doing not overhauls the mission
because you know the mission up to that
point had really just been to
go out into you know the country set
ambushes where you could you know see if
you could find the enemy although they
hadn't had any success but just because
they hadn't had success um wires doesn't
say that you know that's an excuse like
like i said you know in the book uh his
his message to his men at the time was
this is the only war in town we're not
going to let it go to waste
and so he sends his guys out every night
and he goes with him i mean they're out
in the muck and the misery of the the
wrong sat special zone
and uh night after night whether you
contact the enemy or not we're going to
be going out
so adapt yourself to that expectation
and and that's the detachment that
restored their prospects it does they i
mean by the end of that deployment i
think they have something like 80 kills
uh most of them are from one single
contact but they
i mean they
they they
they make things easier for themselves
they they create like a houseboat uh of
an old world war ii era landing craft um
they make it so they don't have to you
know return to base so often they
improve their living conditions um they
essentially
just start going out for a few hours at
a time
and finding the enemy where possible
responding to
reports of
enemy contact and then you know
patrolling to those areas
and they get you know they're not you
know this you know they're not what we
understand to be the seals uh today but
they're they're awfully close
what was the operation jack's day
operation jack's day is a attempt it was
a sort of a marine corps navy mission
right at the beginning
right when um
debt uh
debt delta gets in country and it's a
sort of a marine corps led mission to
sort of sweep
this one uh suspected corner of the
rungsat special zone and it's uh
i i think they claim it you know to be
this you know um huge success when in
fact it's it's a bit of a disaster um
there's multiple heat casualties in the
process there is a there are a couple of
enemy kills i think the only thing real
that they find in the entire three week
long mission is a
a vietcong
hospital sort of a built up section of
log pathways and little huts and other
than that they don't find much
seal teams try to contribute to it udts
contribute to it the udts bring
i i cut a bit of a section of the book
on operation jack's day
it was it was mostly a litany of of
failures by both the seals and the udts
they had bad gear they had you know they
they just they they their contribution
wasn't significant um
so
and you mentioned guy stone
when you were talking about wagner what
was his guy stone he didn't get much in
the book
he gets a he gets a a brief um uh you
know nod and that's um
he
helps um
he's he's
wagner's best friend he's wagner's best
friend in the world
he helps uh set up the pru uh training
camp
but he's also important because he was a
korean war soldier he was a forward
observer in the us army so when
the leadership at seal team one is
trying to you know adapt you know their
naval commando force to be
to you know to have more you know hard
army skills who do they turn to you know
outside of you know their traditional uh
avenues for support with you know the
ranger school and things like that they
turn to a former soldier guy stone guy
stone sets up a curriculum
he gets smart on all of his old army
manuals and he sets up training for seal
team one and starts putting all the guys
through it before they go to vietnam
they got to go through geystone's course
uh
so they managed to and again i mean
there's so that you have so many good
stories in there about what what
happened what this looked like who these
characters were um
now we move into uh chapter 14.
the direct action seals who dodged the
version then perfected a mission that
propelled the teams past the riverbanks
into history
going to the book here
in the winter of 1956 robert t gallagher
joined udtr and i said that already
today one time but this is what buds
used to be called was udtr which is
universal uh
underwater demolition teams replacement
training
so
gallagher joined udtr class 17 at little
creek a class comprised of 97 personnel
including five navy officers five u.s
army soldier graduates from ranger
school and one black sailor from ohio
who remarkably had taught himself to
swim in a creek after a town order to
integrate the local pool had prompted
the owner to fill it with rocks
[Music]
how did you dig up that piece of
information
i mean that was from bill goins he was
you know the first uh first black seal
he'd been one of the plank owners
at um seal team two and he's you know
just i mean
he's still still alive and still
um contributing he's helping with the
navy's uh recruitment efforts of uh of
black sailors i mean he's uh of you know
minorities he's he's an incredible
person and there's not a trace of you
know bitterness i mean he's just
i mean he has every every right to be
bitter you know for you know everything
that he went through and he's just
talking to him is just
it's just such a you know it's a
pleasure to talk to him let's get him on
the podcast
um at one point in the first few weeks
of the temperature had dropped so low
that gallagher and his classmates had
been forced to break the ice that had
crusted the edge of the chesapeake bay
so their instructors could torture them
in it a ritual not unheard of in udt's
east coast winter classes
after four weeks of this four weeks of
heaving logs over windswept sand dunes
four weeks of wet fatigues freezing to
their skin four weeks of elephant
marches with boats on their head
a misery that had rubbed gallagher's
thinning weed already thin thinning
widows peak raw more than 50 percent of
the class had quit including one of the
navy officers and all five of the ranger
school graduates
it was just too psychological for them
one man remembered
and there had been so much farther to go
after a total of 16 weeks class 17 had
shrunk to a mere shadow of itself
of the 97 who had started
only 14 graduated
one of those incidentally was the
undaunted black sailor from ohio another
of course was gallagher
gallagher's subsequent career in the
udts was more than commendable when
wherever he went he excelled and more
this reputation plus his standing as a
sturdy drinker had made him a natural
choice for the first batch of frogmen to
join seal team 2.
there he had excelled again undertaking
the most difficult assignments including
a course to qualify as an explosive
ordnance disposal technician or eod tech
one of the military's more cerebral
ratings and an eight-month overseas
advisory billet to istanbul where he
helped train the first all-turkish navy
udt class
from these assignments it was possible
for gallagher's peers to assemble a
portrait of his personality hard
charging and intense yet entirely devoid
of pretense
when deployed it was only on the rare
occasion he was seen in anything but a
grumpled pair of udt shorts
he was above all known for his quiet
confidence the oxygen of of his
leadership but with the emphasis on
quiet
he had all the sensitivity of a rock
remembered one teammate unless at a bar
the only place he seemed to allow his
sense of humor to walk around off leash
he was just more pulled into himself
than others remembered a teammate just
tough to get to know
for the first of it for for the force of
his personality for his combat
experience gallagher was from the moment
he joined the seventh platoon's
unofficial leader
no one argued with him said roy matthews
about to depart on his first deployment
you might win the fight but you'd never
want to go to sleep again
the reality was actually
less slightly less severe certainly
gallagher was all the aforementioned was
remote intense almost humorless but
there was another quality that would
soon help him become one of the best
combat leaders in the history of the
navy essentially an orphan from the day
gallagher had joined the seals they had
been whether they knew it or not his
family
nothing matters nothing mattered as much
to him nothing except maybe the mission
a mission whose evolution would have no
greater contributor than gallagher
he's a
i don't i don't even know where to start
with callier i i always i say that i
don't like the term hero but if i have
to
if you had to pick one or if you had to
pick a person
you know to kind of
you know set up as a
as an example for young frogman this is
it
he's the anti marcinko
you know the
he's the
he's not
boastful he's not
he never
never stretched the truth on anything
that he ever did
partly because he just never talked
about what he did
i mean he
i managed to talk to you know i mean i
interviewed a lot of people for the book
um and i'd always find a way to you know
convince somebody to to talk to me um
i when i when i finally
was able to track gallagher down
uh
you know i kind of
took a deep breath
dialed the number
um
he answered the phone
i hastily ran high this is ben milligan
i'm writing a history that i'm a former
seal blah blah trying to get through
like um
you know my introduction um
tell them you know i'm
gonna be writing about the seventh
platoon would love to hear your
perspective i've talked to many of your
teammates talk to pete peterson and talk
to roy matthews i've talked to you know
all these guys um would love to get your
perspective um if you have time
he
right here
he takes a pause and he goes i don't
think i want to do that then he hangs up
all the work that i had done that was
that huh
that was your interview that was it did
you ever get anything else out of him
nope
never did talk to everybody i mean
everyone in his orbit um
learned i mean learned as much about him
as i've learned about anybody he had uh
when you were reading through that you
know there was stuff that didn't make
the book like when i say he's
essentially an orphan i mean
he's essentially an orphan and i hope
that you know a reader or listener you
know has a you know some sense of what
that means
like his childhood was nothing less than
heartbreaking his father abandoned uh
him
and his sister him and his brother and
his sister to a uh
then their mother who uh had
tuberculosis uh essentially to a
sanatorium when the mother died um both
uh
um bob and his sister were placed in two
separate uh orphanages um
who at the time i believe was only
around four years old his sister was two
and a half and they were so close
inseparable that every night bob would
escape
his dormitory in the orphanage sneak
across this really really wide expanse
of field between the girl's dormitory
sneak into the girl's dorm and sneak
into her bed just so she wouldn't have
to sleep alone and this is when he was
four years old yeah how did you get this
information from his niece who was
essentially raised like i mean not i
don't know if he
she was very close to her uncle
um
he uh
but he had he i mean it wasn't just the
war that you know made him or just
combat that that made him uh you know
insular and um you know shut off from
everybody he was
he i think you know the fates kind of
contributed you know to to create that
person and he was
not a broken person but he had a real
hard time relating to the folks you know
he
had a you know a bad relationship with
his own children um
uh his uh it was estranged from his wife
his wife never divorced him
but he was estranged from her
and he you know he had a just a really
you know tough time i think the only
person that he was really close to
in life aside from you know his
teammates
aside from you know somebody like pete
peterson
was his sister
as a side note
this last
muster
down at fort pierce
they had you know because of kovid
have you ever been to fort pierce and
they do the muster they haven't been to
the muster but but i know about the ash
swim but tell everyone that's awesome so
they were doing uh an ash's swim and
they uh every year at fort pierce um
once a year they will do an ashes swim
so if anyone connected to nsw has died
in the previous year and they would like
their ashes to be committed to the the
ocean
they will that they do a sunrise uh swim
out into the atlantic
and
two of your teammates will escort your
ashes out into the sea and they'll
release release their ashes i'd never
been to one of these things
i'd heard about them
uh this year i was uh invited down to uh
to give a talk on the history of the
teams and uh they
asked me if i would you know participate
the next morning in one of these
you know swims
i knew pete peterson was going to be
there i met you know i interviewed pete
a number of times for the book and
i knew that he was going to be swimming
bob's ashes bob died several months
before
and he was going to be swimming bob's
ashes
in addition to bob's ashes there were
two other members of the seventh platoon
that were whose ashes were going to be
swum out
so i you know i
told pete if you need you know a swim
buddy for this i'm happy to happy to
join you and he was more than happy to
accept so the next morning we're out
there
you know 4 a.m they want us to all
muster um you know kind of backed by the
museum away from the ocean
and it's november and it's pretty cold
and probably the high 40s um and you
know we're just out there in swim trunks
with you know flippers and you know
they're going down the roster okay all
right here's the here's a name you know
uh here bob bob gallagher who's swimming
bob you know pete you know he's in his
mid 80s at this point he raises his hand
he's you know got uh um he's an old he's
an older guy um
but he's uh i'm i'm swimming bob it's
like all right who's swimming with pete
like i shot my hand up so fast i'm
swimming with pete
um
but after you know you get your
assignments you know right you know
before sunrise they march you out and i
was not
expecting
you know sort of the spectacle of what
was out there they had a
shadow box set up for
uh
every person whose ashes were being swum
out so about 40 different uh shadow
boxes with a you know flag and then uh
behind that you know facing the ocean
probably about 50 50 50 people uh per
shadow box
of family members that were all
assembled there to watch uh their loved
ones ashes being swum out to someone not
to see they had a you know bagpipes at a
navy band they had a flag team um it was
it was a huge huge collection of
thousands of people on the beach
uh they do a flag ceremony
so they kind of they they
position the swimmers you know
behind the shadow box facing the family
they go down one by one and they'll do a
you know presentation of the flag to the
family
now they you know set us up me and you
know me and pete behind bob's ashes but
right next to bob's family
they had uh
uh roy matthews who was also in the
seventh platoon and they also had ron
yaw ranio's family was right there too
and they were both members of the
seventh platoon and i'm standing there
with pete
who was you know their oic you know in
uh in vietnam and you can see pete's
getting pete's getting emotional here i
don't blame him i would have been too
and uh i'm starting to think you know
seeing pete
and they finally you know after the flag
presentation they hand you the ashes and
they hand you know hand bob's ashes you
know to us
bob's at least 20 pounds i mean the bag
of ashes it's pretty heavy
um i'm looking at you know pete and they
finally tell us you know about face
start marching into the ocean we start
backing up or
guys are getting online you know um
you know putting fins on
pete's having you know a little bit of a
tough time getting those those fins on
i'm starting to see the the line you
know kind of edge away from us a little
bit like we're starting to be like all
right me and peter starting to get left
behind here a little bit like i'm
starting to wonder if you know the waves
are
pretty big for florida i've never seen
waves that big in florida but we're
starting to back into it i'm looking at
pete and i'm like pete
we don't have to do this man we can find
somebody else to swim you know bob out
we'll take care of this if you can't you
can't do this pete looks at me and he
goes i think there's really only one
thing to do here
and uh like all right i start to grab
his arm like we're gonna head back in he
takes off
like he dies through that wave
he went from being like an 83 year old
man to a 25 year old frog man like that
i couldn't keep up with him i'm doing
everything i can to swim dragon bomb
through the surf
and uh
finally we
get out there through the breakers sun
comes up
uh command comes out
i hand uh i hand bob to uh to pete pete
lets them go
i mean the whole
whole thing
the whole ten years of work
on this book
that it was it was worth it in that
moment
man
uh
but
i mean you you can see it like you see
it there like you see like
i mean even the guys i i've been talking
to guys that are you know
from that era
guys that aren't even mentioned in the
book
but they are you know to a man they are
you know
they all express you know how pleased
they are that you know bob's
uh contribution
you know bob gallagher who's you know
never
you know never you know
uh touted his own achievements
um
i mean if anybody's going to you know
uh
capture the you know the attention of
that era i mean
that should be him
there's an interesting thing about him
too that i mean he like i i say he's the
anti-marxinko he's he's he's not you
know he's not a
he he had such pride in the rest of the
the navy like in in a way that i you
know i when i set out to write this book
i always assumed that i'd be writing a
book that you know confirmed all the
myths about us that we did all this
ourselves you know and then the navy you
know was always the you know the the
branch of the the parent command was
trying to keep us you know assigned to
the water when i found the opposite to
be true and then when i discovered bob
gallagher bob gallagher's lasting legacy
if anything is you know how much pride
he had not just in the seal teams but in
his parents service too he left the seal
teams one of the last things he did he
took a commission
which no i don't know that anybody i
knows about it but he he took a
commission uh as a
warrant officer and one of the first
things he did was he had to leave the
seal teams he had to go to an aircraft
carrier and uh
and and work on this aircraft carrier
with fleet sailors and
every every seal that he ever met
afterwards he
to a man he told them it was one of the
things he was most proud of he was able
to see you know the u.s navy at work uh
and see how committed you know
his fellow shipmates and sailors were
you know they weren't seals
maybe these guys couldn't uh you know
couldn't couldn't run and couldn't do
the things that frogmen can do but they
still had pride in their work and they
still you know had a mission to do and
and he was you know every bit as proud
of that as he was of his you know career
in the teams
when when did you what stood out um
how did you get to
that that platoon
you know i
um i spent you know a long time
a long time trying to figure out where
that transition had occurred
you know that uh transition from
where the seal platoons were you know uh
patrol and ambushers uh to you know
capture kill commandos and you know
marcinko he makes all these claims in
his you know rogue warrior book um that
it was his platoon that was the eighth
platoon that made that transition
um
and i went through and i i was gathering
as many you know barn dance cards or
after action reports as i could um and
you know i was going through operation
by operation platoon by platoon trying
to see like you know who had made that
transition i went through eighth platoon
you know among others i was you know i
was plotting insertion points extraction
points actions on objective uh points
for every one of their missions and you
know after you know doing three months
worth of marcinko's missions i realized
every claim that he had made in rogue
warriors
like
what which is sad because you know what
his platoon did was totally commendable
it was it was incredible like what his
platoon did and their contribution to
chow duck during the tet offense is
amazing
but you know he he was making you know
outlandish claims and you know and not
only burnishing his legacy but doing it
at the expense of other folks too i
couldn't understand why he was
um
but i mean i found the seven platoon
because i was just methodically going
through these platoons you know platoon
at a time operation by at a time
and i noticed in the seven platoons you
know this
they started out like everybody else you
know they they got to you know vietnam
and they would get a little bit of intel
and they would go out they'd set an
ambush they'd uh
they'd patrol to contact um but by you
know the three-month mark in their
deployment their their their their
operations take a noticeable turn and
this is when they meet uh their
interpreter uh min who's a a former or
who's a vietnamese sailor and they
enlist him into the organization he's
not just an interpreter though he's like
he's a source of intel like he's uh he's
able to connect them to um you know
institutions in the country that you
know provide them a wealth of
information and then they start going
out and they they're not just going out
for viet cong they're going out for viet
cong with names they know who they're
going after
so you know that the seven i'm seven
platoon makes that
makes that turn and by the end of that
uh platoon
uh by this by the by the summer of 1968
uh the platoon that that followed the
the the seventh platoon uh they're you
know they're they're doing what the
seventh platoon did but only but
better better but i mean rudy bosch you
know rolls in with the 10th platoon and
every platoon then it it franchises at
that point every platoon whether it's a
seal an east coast platoon or a west
coast platoon they're all doing it
they're all you know relying on this
capture kill mission and it doesn't
really start to trickle off
until uh
you know the the war really starts to uh
um
uh drive uh the the end of uh
uh the the funnel the the money starts
to shut off you know they stop getting
you know rounds for their uh uh m16s
they
they don't get any more gas money for
their jeeps they take jeeps away from
them they make them start doing watch
standing uh on on various bases that
they're on so all the intel collection
that they've been doing up to that point
in the war it's starting to get you know
they're not able to do it like they were
in like you know 69 70 71.
well first of all
you want to you want to get some seals
mad make them stand watch oh yeah
i read that these guys get so bad
we had
we had uh uh to stand watch we had to
stand watching people we captured
actually when my first deployment to
iraq
and
you would have thought like i could say
hey guys get jocked up we got a qrf to
do wherever but get your gear on we're
going into freaking hell guys would be
like cool but you say hey i know we just
did that mission you gotta stay and
watch at five o'clock in the morning you
kidding me
he's so pissed off
uh i would take that i would take the
two o'clock in the morning to four
o'clock myself in the and the aoic would
take the worst watch of the night the
one that you had to wake up in the
middle of the night you know the other
ones you could kind of sleep until
uh no not us but guys don't like stand
and watch the other thing that's
interesting about this is
you know having talking to heaven having
talked to
a number of sog guys
man they were so compartmentalized
they would get like no turnover things
would happen they would never tell
anybody right and i mean i'm talking
like lesson learned from an operation
hey don't
use this type of weapon in this
situation they'd never hear that it was
well not never but it was very limited
to how much they would be able to pass
on or that they would receive it would
all be kind of centralized like maybe to
be one guy that would debrief them uh so
the fact that the the seals were sharing
hey this is a better way to do
operations here as well how we can make
a
huge impact that's important from a
leadership perspective when you're out
there working in a company in a business
and a team when you learn something pass
it on so everyone can benefit the other
thing that was like
i mean totally benefited the seals at
this point is you know this uh policy
that the rest of the military had of
individual rotation they thought that
having you know uh you know oh yeah
constant you know presence there you
know was was easier to you know keep all
the equipment there but we'll just you
know feed guys onesie twosies into into
a unit it's horrible it's terrible yeah
you know they get to country nobody
knows them nobody trusts them they don't
know anybody else nobody wants to train
them never never never they've never
worked together the green berets did
that the lerps did that i mean all these
special units that we call special you
know they are learning together
as they operate all the time all the
time the best guys are getting pulled
out
whereas the seal teams they were always
deploying as a group they were coming
home as a group they were training
together and they would redeploy as a
group yeah and by the way you get
turnover operations not like this
everyone shows up and now no one knows
what to do you get turnover operations
and there's a period two week period
yeah so it's not like you're wait
doesn't it kind of make sense to have
new guys cycling and that way you still
got some experience guys no it doesn't
gotta work together yeah
uh
moving on to chapter 15. and i think
this might be echo's favorite title
right here
the navy's skeleton key to inland combat
and the final
against the current achievements in the
war's ebb tide that exposed the seals
preeminence as the u.s military's go
anywhere commandos
i even got you laughing at this bed your
editor
well i
in my editor's defense i'm the one that
wrote the
titles
but as you said it kind of explains us
you know what's going on here a little
bit
uh let me go to the book
within two months of his arrival zomwalt
that's the admiral's omalt strategy
zumwalt's strategy had pulled swift
boats from the coastal blockade to take
over the pbr patrols
in the lower delta and had reclaimed
some 90 percent of the vessels assigned
to the mobile riverine force to push
into bloody alley of the parrot's beak
that portion of cambodi that stabbed the
insurgency supply lines like a knife
into the delta's heart
with zumwalt's arrival the seals went
from being the fleet's project prodigal
stepchild raiders to the fleet's
skeleton key to inland opportunities
opportunities for navy boats navy ships
navy fighters navy helicopters navy gun
ships navy intelligence officers even
navy seabees
to goose the navy's involvement in seal
operations zumwalt always wearing forest
green fatigues and occasionally
accompanied by a camera and crew and
reporters routinely dropped in on his
platoons and always posed a variant of
the same question
how can i help
[Music]
in short order that help was showing up
in piastre's for hoi chan's and
interpreters navy jeeps to meet with
sources daily grocery drops by the
navy's helicopter transports
after the friendly fire death of
lieutenant junior grade david nichols
zumwalt took less than three days to
invest in
invest one seal compound with an actual
navy physician
all told it was the kind of self-serving
that helped infuse the seals with an
even greater operational capacity so
much so that within six months of
zumwalt's arrival the headquarters of
the seals task group commander in
vietnam was finally upgraded from a
cluttered desk at ctf-116
to an entire kwanzan hut
i need 15 more 20 more 100 more seals
remembered three war veteran frogman
frank kane of zumwalt's repeated calls
to increase his compliment
when such requests collided with the
reality of seal's actual manning numbers
no
levels nowhere close to the green berets
zumwalt even enlisted the efforts and
advice of the commander of u.s naval
forces in the philippines none other
than the bull frog himself admiral
draper kaufman
so
that's a huge turning point when you
start getting this massive support
from zumwalt
yeah i mean the seals are no longer like
they're not no longer at the fringe of
the navy's operations they're the
um
they're the they're the harpoon
uh
that you know not only is you know
striking
you know into the heart of the enemy but
just like a harpoon it's attached to a
rope it's pulling the rest of the navy
inland
yeah
that little detail that you got in there
of zumwalt always wearing camis or
always wearing fatigues that's just like
yeah i mean it's a
you're always on the lookout for
whatever you know that little detail
that's gonna you know
it's gonna say something else to your
reader you know you
i mean just just the fact that
you know his
his sideburns alone like convey to the
rest of his sailors that hey i'm cool
i'm cool like you
you know like
i mean up to that point in uh you know
in the navy
um
there's no beards allowed i mean when he
becomes cnn you know what's back in you
know back in fashion in the u.s navy
beards he brings it all back
but i mean he's he's totally you know he
he's a he's a i'm he has the
bona fide is to do it he's um
he's a junior officer all through the uh
through world war ii he's one of the
only sailors uh to to take a ship up uh
the wempo river into shanghai he
actually sees what saco is doing at the
tail end of world war ii he turns over
or he
does a prisoner exchange with with phil
bucklew
in 1945. he's seen
even if he's not participated in it he's
gotten a glimpse of what the navy is
capable of and when he gets there to
vietnam he knows the navy could be doing
more
and then you know not not only is his
role as the commander of naval forces in
vietnam important but he's the one that
ultimately becomes a chief of naval
operations he's
he thought the seals were you know
important before i mean when he becomes
a cno
i mean you're vaulting the seals uh
preeminence now with it along with him
so pretty neat the zumwalt class ships
uss mikey monsoor oh it's incredible
yeah just i mean that that connection is
yeah that's it's so cool
uh
how about
as this is you know you got
trying to put together like
bob carey's mission
how hard was that
it's not uh bob carey's mission is it's
sort of um it's sort of a one-off
like and i thought you know i thought
about focusing on on bob carey's mission
for the chapter but it's
it's it's not a
it's not like an indicator of like the
navy's inland adventurism because it's
right on the coast it's right in natrang
bay what uh what signifies that it's um
important in you know like the
um
the seals sort of like elbowing out its
competitors is the fact that it's
right around the corner from where the
green berets are operating like that's
their that's their corner of the war so
yeah it's coastal but it should have
been in the green berets territory and
here comes you know seal team one along
with ctf 115 ctf 115 is the coastal
squadron um or the coastal task force uh
they get their first seals and what do
they do with them they start sending
them everywhere um and it is it's one of
the
i mean you look at that that mission and
it is it's so different from what the
the rest of the seal uh teams are doing
in the mekong delta um but it's so
indicative of um
you know this this transformation that
the seals have gone through they're not
uh a you know patrol and ambush force
anymore now they're going after
individual viet cong so they can capture
them
flip them
and or ransack them for you know other
locations
so the whole mission is not a
this is an entrepreneurial this is not a
you know
let's see let's see what we get they
know who they're going for they've got
good information and they you know they
plan um a really cool
uh special operation to go get them
did you feel tempted to get sucked into
the sea wolves at all oh yeah
because oh yeah i've had the scene i had
to i had to keep them at arm's length
i was like i i don't have time i was
like i i would find i i found some i had
i had a lot of documents about the sea
wolves too i was like
man
and there i mean navy
just the
navy
you know gunship squadrons alone i mean
they've gone through you know very very
similar you know
you know experience of let's bring them
back let's disband them again bring them
back disband them again like well you
and i experienced that i mean we had the
reserve squadrons that were
working pretty much as the sea wolves
did they were like at the beck and call
of the seals you know my first
deployment to iraq it was we worked with
those guys all the time they were our
full support and they were fantastic
fantastic uh but the sea wolves in nam
man commissioned in vietnam and
decommissioned the only squadron ever to
be commissioned in combat and
decommissioned in combat
there's that one story
they they
they're running out of fuel there's a
platoon on the ground they're like we're
not leaving one bird's like hey we're
not leaving we'll just run out of gas so
they
have enough gas to get in there and grab
the last few guys but they don't have
enough gas to make it back to base they
land in the middle of a rice rice patty
somewhere and they're using an ammo can
to
siphon fuel into an ammo can and pour it
into the hue
to get that thing back to base bro
these guys when you talk to in the
vietnam guys that the vietnam skills
i've had in the podcast like you they
they just lo absolutely without question
love the sea wolf guys because those
seawolf guys
they took so much risk to support the
seals on the ground
you know when i was uh
there were a couple episodes when i was
um i would come i would i would see like
a report of an army slick who you know
said well we're not going to land or
something like that and then the report
of a sea wolf pilot saying well if you
don't land i'm going to shoot you down
and i was i was a little skeptical that
i was like i don't know if that's that's
uh that's cricket and then i found
another one i was like i'm wondering if
this happened maybe a couple of times
no i made it into the book i mean not to
you know never diminish what those uh
army slick pilots did they were i mean
they were doing the lord's work too but
yeah and then and then as you're trying
to get like the last three years of the
war yeah to compress that how hard was
that it was tough i i had to
you know um i realized uh that i made my
point i i knew that you know i'd
accomplished what i set forth the to to
establish which is you know the moment
when the seals became what we are today
you know um so now all i'm always trying
to do is just kind of
one you know uh further solidify you
know how that had happened and you know
i discovered some stuff along the way
like you know the um
the ninth or the ninth division being
you know the night
one of the most interesting things to
you know show you know how the
the navy had become you know so you know
important in the mekong delta is you
know finally the ninth division starts
copying uh the seals the the lerps um
start to
deconflict uh areas um and take them
away from the seals and the seals are
you know they want to go out and you
know do this raid and they can't because
the army is already there um and
it the very good chance that if the war
had continued on you know for a little
bit longer uh that uh the army would
have you know taken all the navy's
missions and the seals would have had to
either move someplace else adapt again
i'm not sure what would have happened
but
there's a good chance that the army's
special operations would have gotten a
lot better a lot a lot better a lot
faster
but they pull the ninth division out of
the country all together leaving the
seal teams
as the only all-american commando force
in the entire fourth corps
for two years
which i mean
talk about opportunity
you know going back to the uh
the sea wolves and them being
answering the call you know that's a
something that i i learned out of the
gate when i got to seal teams was that
hey in nam
if it was a platoon in trouble or if it
was a down pilot we were going bright
light no questions asked
that's a
that's that's a that's an attitude that
stuck through you know till this day
something's going on like that we're
going
i i mean and
whatever
i don't know if it was pulled from
you know the sea wolves but
i mean we we saw it carry through i mean
in our time i mean
the uh
seal team 10
i mean they came to the you know rescue
of uh you know their
sdv squad
um
the uh
uh gold squadron seals
i mean they they were on their way to
you know come to the aid of army rangers
yeah
like were they in trouble yeah
is it dangerous yep
are you gonna go we sure are yep
um
i don't know i mean it's
if americans are in trouble i mean
you're going to go
um
i mean that's
you know when you start talking about
tommy norris and his activities
yeah i mean that's that's
exactly right like you i mean how much
did tommy risk
uh you know to come
to rescue somebody who he never knew i
think 11 other americans had died
attempting to uh to rescue you know
those those two you know the pilot in
the navigator uh he um
and not only i mean he had you know
he was there with
uh his vietnamese rangers okay i mean
like the thing that never you know
ceases to amaze me is the fact that the
seal teams were the recipient of all of
that accumulated knowledge of all that
um
of all that legacy you know you know
darby's legacy and the cabana twin
legacy and the point to hawk all that
you know all that knowledge got
compressed into the ranger school and
there are no rangers so the seal teams
became the biggest
uh
you know collection of ranger school
graduates in the us military
and then you know not only you know is
there that connection with uh tommy
norris you know leading vietnamese
rangers but uh the um
the seals and uh the the seventh platoon
seals uh during the tet offensive mito
the uh bob gallagher leads a squad of
seals uh you know through the streets of
mito to uh to help call in uh airstrikes
for the the stranded vietnamese seals or
vietnamese rangers um
but yeah bob yeah our uh you know tommy
norris coming you know
risking everything and and his he and
his rangers had undergone you know a uh
pretty pretty terrible uh mortar uh
attack the night before he went out on
that raid or went out on that rescue
mission uh i don't i can't remember off
the top of my head how many of his of
his rangers were killed in that attack
but i mean
combat ineffective he only had a handful
of rangers left and him and kit you know
still decide
there's an american in trouble we're
going to get them
it's just remarkable to me it goes out
and
um talking to
so you ask the question how do you
compress you know essentially what's a
three year period of history into a
single you know 15 page chapter
and
you know you have two of you know the
most
you know
iconic seal missions of the war that
occurred during this period are not two
but multiple i mean you've got you know
bob carey's mission you've got uh tommy
norris's mission you've got uh
thornton's mission to rescue norris
at some point i had the idea like i
can't cover all that um and it's not not
necessarily it's not outside the scope
of what i was doing but it's redundant
to what i've already shown so i don't
need to do that but i do want to cover
it in some and and you know pay it or
not or you know
describe it in a way that other folks
probably haven't and i had read
you know the books on uh tommy
and and mike thorne and i'd read the
book on
tommy rescuing or the most recent books
on uh those events
and the things that i noticed that they
didn't cover
were the medal of honor ceremonies uh
for each event and i thought wouldn't
that be an interesting
way to you know wrap up the book
with this you know with tommy norris's
uh medal of honor ceremony because mike
thornton's medal of honor ceremony
happened several years earlier
tommy's doesn't happen until 1976.
vietnam war is over fall of saigon has
happened
you can capture all of this here this
history that's happened if you you know
use that that moment as a vehicle so
that's what i did i uh i contacted you
know tommy norris and he was
um you know who i can't i who
mark robbins who was on that deployment
uh lost his eye um to a machine gunner's
bullet um
tommy had been uh tommy had uh helped
counsel him through you know the
um
you know losing the eye and um
so mark had tommy's phone number so i
just cold called him one day got him on
the phone and
um had us you know kind of kind of a
series of talks with him but
he just couldn't have been you know
just a more accessible more um
more friendly guy just a humble humble
guy you know considering everything he's
been through everything he's done
and you know what was funny is he always
you know he he didn't minimize what he i
mean he did minimize what he did but he
also like was so proud of you know his
post-war you know career in the fbi he
had this like
i mean he had a he had a i mean in
addition to his you know seal career he
had this legendary fbi career he was you
know he was a undercover agent
um he was going after international
terrorists as an undercover agent and
his his um his cover was that of like a
a one-eyed arms dealer and nobody ever
doubted him
like uh
he was a um
uh he was you know he went after white
supremacists and idaho uh he one of the
best stories that i i heard about him
was that
he was up on a wire
and he had been listening to this white
supremacist for a few months
and he knew that this guy one
had this uh this big rottweiler that it
was his pride and joy he loved this dog
and he was taking him to the vet um
for some you know not not serious issue
but he was gonna leave the the dog there
overnight so tommy you know having
listened to this guy's voice for like a
month he could imitate him pretty well
so uh the night the dog was there tommy
makes a phone call to the vet he's like
hey uh while the dog's there why don't
you go ahead and neuter him
i don't know if it's true
i don't know i don't know this is an
accurate story but this is all
it didn't get in the book because i
couldn't verify it
the other story that i heard and this
was from a vietnam era seal who was one
of the first team leaders at hrt
so he had
so tommy wasn't one of the founders of
hrt but he was one of the plank owners
he was one of the first guys to go
through
the hrt selection
um and
so hrt was in
they were conducting one of their very
first operations in 1985 it was against
a or they were trying to
apprehend a
puerto rican nationalist who would it
was a semi it was like essentially it
was a terrorist um but they were
conducting a i believe in a rest warrant
and they were uh going up this guy the
stairs to this guy's house he leans over
the balcony with a machine gun and
stitches the entire assault team
and shoots one operator in the eye
they the team backs out and uh you know
charles or sandy prudy who's a silver
star seal himself uh
the team leader uh for for hrt um he's
trying to um you know come up with a
plan to go in and get this guy
tommy comes running up to san diego
sandy i got a plan to get get this guy
he's like all right tommy what's the
plan how about i run upstairs and kill
him
check
um
freaking outstanding uh
i don't know if we could find a better
place to wrap it up than that uh
the book is awesome um
you know we've we've been in and out of
different stories uh we not even
touching what's in this book this big
this book is just
absolutely filled with incredible stuff
um
it's incredible story so get the book
uh echo you got anything
i don't
you sure
i'm sure all right ben i've kept you
captive speaking of hostage rescue
uh i think you're gonna get busted out
of here in a second somebody's probably
looking for you so
i appreciate you coming i can't thank
you enough this is a
is a treat for me anytime i get to talk
about this stuff is uh that's great
thanks for the support of the book too
this is
all right
i can't thank you enough
well uh
the amount of effort that you put in
this book the product is just
outstanding and i can't even fathom that
there would be someone else that would
go through the effort that you did
to
to do this you know you're like you got
issues dude
[Music]
leaving the teams is a dramatic event
that's dramatic which you have proved
look at this
look at the i mean the infrastructure
that's surrounding you at this point
it's a you have to do something
to account for that trauma
and i always used to think that i was
immune to you know you know leaving
leaving the teams and i was never going
to you know fill it with anything else
and you know i'd never gotten any
tattoos i'd never you know i didn't get
into triathlons or anything like that um
i just had this huge blind spot creeping
up on me that i didn't even know about
and uh
once
once this thing
found me
i mean i was
i was hostage to it like there wasn't
anything i mean it was it dominated my
life i mean it was
you know i don't i try to really
you know curtail the amount of time that
i put into it i'd only work in the
morning and work in the evening you know
after the kids were in bed
um but what i found was that i would
leave off uh writing or researching
um and then throughout the day this
thing would just be on a loop in my head
and i couldn't break away
and that was like that for ten years
when you when it got published were you
already thinking about your next book oh
you just like
you know i'm not a breather so i when i
was writing the book i had kind of a
i was
if i wasn't thinking about a paragraph
or a specific um you know issue i i had
this sort of mental loop going on in my
head and it was always like
what's the point what's the point what's
the point what's the point what's the
point of this book what's the point of
this chapter what's the point of the
sentence what am i doing what what's the
point what's the point what's the
purpose and that that question was
always on a loop in my head
and then when i
turned the final manuscript in
and i was done
and i didn't have that question to think
about
i i was a little lost
and i found myself like i took a walk in
my neighborhood and i was just
and all of a sudden i found myself
and sort of uh subconsciously
thinking
i started to say
what's next what's next what's next
what's next yeah just kind of just
and i've fortunately through a lot of
counseling no
through some distance from the book i've
been able to you know take a take a
pause i kind of gave myself you know
mentally a year
you know from the date of publication
uh until
you know so from a year so july 20th
when it came out
um
i'm giving myself until july 20th of
2022 before i really start
you know buckling down or start beating
myself up about what's next
so
a psycho because
we might once i get done as soon as i
get done and turn the final manuscript
well first of all before that even
happens i'm already plotting i already
got that next book
one of them has bubbled to the surface
and i'm ready to rock and roll and so by
the time the book comes out when it when
one one of my books gets published the
other one is already
it's already being formulated and kind
of being written
which is
really annoying because i also have like
the repeat loop in my head like oh this
could be good the squeaky one as soon as
that i go there's no there's no moment
to go ah
no
there's no yeah no yeah so i mean there
was maybe
a an afternoon i did reward myself at
the end of each chapter i would get i
would get drunk
and i wouldn't go out drinking or
anything like that i never did i would
just when you got done with the chapter
would it be
like that's the rough chapter or is that
like hey i mean yeah it was the first
draft i knew that i was coming back yeah
yeah um but i i mean just getting you
know you know putting that flag on the
ground and being like i'm done with that
chapter like i felt like you know even
if i knew that it wasn't perfect
if i knew if i was going to have to come
back at least i knew the meat was there
meat was there the content was there and
and
i if i had let myself you know get that
far then i knew what the point of the
chapter was i knew why that chapter was
important and i knew the point that i
was trying to make so at least i had the
you know the bones of the chapter the
structure was good you know whether or
not i was going to come back and add
stuff on you know the
cuban frogmen or something like that or
um uh
gosh
where are you leaning towards your next
book you must be you must have an idea
in that i have an idea but it's very
private
private all right
no one's going to steal any of your
ideas it's not that because no one has
enough time
it has nothing to do with that is that i
need i need that in my head
i if i say it out loud for for whatever
reason it will it'll be like
um i i need the motivation of it i need
the the unfinished uh quality of it to
motivate me too
that's
one thing i noticed is
in uh seal training
uh guys that were like saying like oh
i'm in seal training i'm in seal
training i'm in seals training those
guys like didn't seem to make it yeah so
maybe it's the same kind of thing for
you you don't want to get it out there
because that's i don't it's almost like
you get rewarded for it you get a little
mini reward
oh wow that sounds awesome you already
got paid yeah you're not allowing
yourself to get paid that's a good move
i like it that's right i like it don't
allow yourself to get paid man don't go
credit don't take credit so you're not
even taking any credit from me from echo
you're just taking nothing from us no i
just have to earn it over here what's in
here i was gonna say because no one's
gonna take your idea about some random
document written in 1953
about some you know new nuclear warhead
that
led to whatever how'd you know yeah
there you go
well awesome man thanks for coming down
um you're welcome back here anytime i've
got some ideas in my head for like some
kind of something to do with some sort
of podcast scenario with you i don't
even know what it is yet but yes
yeah i agree we'll work something out
like that
uh i'm i'm i'm committing oh so right on
you see well you know i kind of feel
like i already did it because i just
said it so it's kind of like i got the
reward i can just move on though you
know it's pretty much done uh hey if you
want to support this podcast get some
jocko fuel we supported this podcast
today you're racking and stacking some
joggers it's been a long day even for
echo charles who's usually in the cruise
mode over there are your vocal cords
tired
[Laughter]
i handled that uh
get some get some stuff from
jackofield.com get some bulk i'm so see
see we haven't eaten today so my mulk
detector is high order right now it's
super hyped right now i don't want
anything else i don't want a steak i
don't want uh a cheeseburger
i don't want a turkey leg i want milk
right now plus as far as your macros go
you're going to need that help this late
in the day yeah did i go catabolic
earlier
you're risking that big time right now
we're not going to let that happen when
you get home we get some milk mulk up in
the system yep and so we're good there
so check that out chocolatefuel.com go
to go to wawa if you want to get some of
these drinks
that are freaking awesome because i you
know did we get jittery today did i get
jittery did you get jittery no you felt
smooth all day they're good for you too
by the way good 100 good for you're not
going to pay any price in the future
are you thinking you're going to get
like type 2 diabetes because you drank
some sugary drink because you're not
because that's sweetened with monk fruit
right there
it's true that's what i'm talking about
uh i mean this is my first energy drink
ever yeah ever i don't think i've ever
had a
uh no yeah dang good move
that's weird what'd you drink in iraq
coffee
okay yeah that'll do it you're a coffee
guy uh vitamin shop2 originusa.com
if you want to get some jeans
if you want to get a belt
if you want to get a wallet if you want
to get a pair of boots if you need a jiu
jitsu jiu-jitsu is going high right now
it's going high order everyone's
training right yeah you're feeling it i
feel it the whole world's training you
training man training the jiu jitsu no i
don't have time
how
for all the fans out there yeah i'm
training a lot
uh
originusa.com go get yourself some cool
stuff all that is made in the united
states of america look we spent
trying to fight communism
we we we fought against communism and
we're still fighting against communism
but it's it's not in the jungles anymore
right now it's it's it's in the it's in
your wallet you can give your money to
a communist country literally you can do
that i recommend you don't
i recommend you don't give money to
communism
i recommend you give it to democracy and
america and hardworking american people
so we're talking about originusa.com go
get some freedom son
as opposed to supporting uniquely
affordable labor oh
that's what they call slave labor that's
what they call slave labor true yeah
we're not down for that cause
jackal store boom represent we're on the
path we're working out we're lifting
sometimes we want to represent you want
a shirt that says discipline equals
freedom on it a hoodie
hat
the word good shirt locker shirt locker
shirt locker that's a uniquely
unique
sometimes
[Music]
either way though what that is it's a
different unique shirt with new unique
designs very um unique
good feedback on those ones yeah good
feedback what's the latest
can you say what the latest was what was
the last the this past one
it's april right now so march was
the one that you came up with a long
time ago everybody must get stoned oh
yeah that one was controversial then
controversial controversial i made it we
made a shirt so i heard from the nom
guys
one nom guy in particular was like yeah
he went to get his gun from the armory
after he had been home
and he went to check out his weapon
someone else had taken it to vietnam his
stoner came back
so a guy took his stoner on deployment
did a six month deployment came back
when he went to pick his weapon up from
the armory etched in the butt stock it
said everybody must get stoned
and i was like that's the best thing
ever you know the stoner machine gun if
you don't know uh
the stoner 63
that's what the that's what a lot of guy
a lot of seals carried in vietnam and
it's a badass weapon so we made that
t-shirt so you could get a cool t-shirt
like that some people didn't like it huh
well they're scared they were they were
thinking we were talking about the
marijuana they they were sensitive to
the controversial nature yeah
some people don't like marijuana some
people don't like guns it it's true you
know they had more to do with guns than
marijuana had actually nothing to do
with well yeah you had a lot of folks
yeah the friction
section was the marijuana not the guns
yeah that's my feedback don't you feel
like you're kind of in a stoked
situation where someone's like oh yeah
bro
everyone must get stoned but what's the
gun well it's a stoner 63. nom what
it's a conversation starter anyways
shirt locker if you want to get cool
stuff check it out jocklestore.com
subscribe to the podcast subscribe to
jockowunderground.com so we can be
standing strong in the event of a
total meltdown of our democratic society
also with that and
you know that is true that is true but
you get life advice every week from
jacob tell me come on every week
life advice you need life advice boom
ass draco every single week yeah i
answer your questions i answer all
there's like a special way to contact us
if you're part of the
of the jocko underground then you can
submit questions when i answer them so
get some of that youtube we got a
youtube channel you can see the videos
that i am the assistant director of
therefore they are awesome
and even the ones that echo just works
on by himself are okay
thank you
uh psychological warfare flip side
canvas dakota meyer he's got cool stuff
to hang on your wall dude if we made a
if we made a ben milligan t-shirt what
would it be
oh i mean you'd sell a dozen
can you imagine
i wonder what could we do what would it
be it'd have to i mean
how pale am i you'd have to be something
like to capture you know this is as tan
as i am
this isn't black and white it only gets
worse yeah if a shirt comes off it's
only worse
so it'd have to be something super white
yeah yeah just like a vague outline
oh do you like do like a white t-shirt
with like a white on white
yeah with like golden like
yeah and then it could just say mulligan
we'll come up with something that's good
uh you'd be surprised man people be
stoked to represent they'd be like
purpose
uh books by water beneath the walls
again
bruh
i know you like the title i get it
i get it next time you're going to title
the book just come and consult come and
consult you got it
hit me up i would spend a 15 minute
conversation there's a beautiful a
beautiful and amazing and powerful and
strong context behind that title
that four people get
and it's and it is as i said this is to
me the most important historical book
about the seals and i'm gonna also say
for me
the most important historical book about
special operations and
you write about everyone in there the
rangers the special forces the scouts
and raiders it's all in there it's just
an outstanding book so pick up that book
buy water beneath the walls
you know what do me a favor right now as
you're listening write this down buy
water beneath walls because there's no
way you're going to remember that
so there you go hey i've written a bunch
of books too final spin
that's that's the novel that i wrote
leadership strategy in tactics field
manual the code the evaluations
protocols display freedom field manual
weigh the warrior kid one two three and
four get those books for the kids that
you know please please do that it will
legitimately guaranteed make their lives
better make them better into better
human beings make them more capable for
the world
and the world is not an easy place mikey
and the dragons get that for the little
munchkins running around the house
about face extreme ownership dichotomy
leadership check out those books as well
echelonfront.com if you need some help
with leadership inside your organization
online training at extremeownership.com
this is not the only place to learn
leadership and leadership is not an
inoculation that you get and now you're
good to go you gotta train just like the
gym that's why we got
extremeownership.com so we can train you
every single day and you wanna ask me
some questions go on there i'm on there
i'm on a zoom call talking to me i'm
five inches away from your head
answering your questions
if you want to help
service members
through an incredible organization go to
americasmightywarriors.org it's mark
lee's mom mama lee
helping in so many different ways she's
tremendous and it's a tremendous
organization don't forget about horses
and heroes micah fink horses heroes and
horses.com
micah fink
he's doing cool stuff on horses
run it rot riding horses through the
wilderness
41 days
legitness um we're on
social media
we're right in there inside the
algorithms don't get sucked into them
i'm at jocko willing echoes that echo
charles ben is at
b milligan three
on instagram and then ben h milligan on
twitter what do you post on instagram
anything yeah i post on there i'll i'll
try and put on like a post a week i'm
not uh i'm not super active on it i'm
i'm not super good uh but i'll
if i'm
um
usually i try and tie something back to
you know american history or something
like that i just i was down at the world
war ii museum um which is incredible um
there was a
right outside the world war two museum
there's a statue of anne frank and they
just happened to position it directly in
front of a shell-packed
section of utah beach that they had
brought back and that seemed like a
wow just an incredible like um
it just i mean it made the whole
the whole effort the whole thing seemed
worthwhile like
just what do these guys do
and what did they do it for it's right
here everything's right here awesome
cool stuff so check out his instagram
and uh ben thanks once again for coming
on i really appreciate it appreciate it
this is fantastic
appreciate what you've done for the
teams uh not only through your service
in the teams but also for this book
and thanks to all the military personnel
out there that are writing history as we
speak by keeping us free around the
world
to the
police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all the first responders
thank you for what you are doing right
now to keep us safe here at home
and
once again
there are
opportunities out there
but they're not gonna just they're not
gonna beat down your door you gotta look
for them you gotta there's an expression
we used to have in the teams
look for work remember that expression
look for work so when you're a new guy
and you're hitting a target a training
operation and you don't really know what
to do so you're kind of standing there
with your weapon at high port not doing
anything and some freaking platoon chief
is gonna go hey willing look for work
and that means you pick up your weapon
and you go look for an angle to cover
well that's what you that's what the
seals did
that's that's where we came from we came
from a position where we were just out
there looking for work don't do what
everyone else is doing
first of all don't just stand there and
do nothing but don't just do what
someone else is doing there it's already
getting done look for the angle that's
not being covered look for the job that
no one else wants look for the job
that is harder that's more complex
that's cold and wet and miserable the
job that requires more effort than
anybody anything
else and more than anybody else is
willing to put up with that's where the
opportunity is
and then go
and get after it
until next time
this has been milligan
and echo and jocko
out